- Dinosaur before.
- We never
- got to taste a dinosaur.
Like a T-Rex probably tasted great.
- Nah, T-Rex would be gamey as (beep).
Are you (beep)ing kidding me?
- Velociraptor is like...
- Good sized, you know,
too muscular though.
- That's true, that would be too tough.
- What's the (beep)in' long
neck (beep) that, uh...
(engaging tones)
Gamers, gamers, gamers.
- I remember whenever
that like message came up
in the cinemas, it like
always just scared me.
- What message?
- That you wouldn't steal a car.
- Why would that...
- Cinemas?
- Why would that become like the standard?
Why did everyone use that one?
- What, that you wouldn't steal a car?
- Yeah, that one, why did
that become the one that...
- 'Cause that's the argument that,
'cause it was the
easiest to like, explain.
- Yeah, but like why did everyone
just take that exact video clip
and use it in everything, like why?
- No, because, did you, were you grow...
Did you grow up in the
Blockbuster era, or like the...
- Yeah, I got games
mainly from Blockbuster.
- Okay, so basically
why that became a meme
is because at the start of every movie
that you rent from, like
Blockbuster or anything,
that one message would show up.
- Yeah, I know that, but then like, what?
It was also in like
non-Blockbuster things,
like why did that video, that thing,
get just used everywhere?
Why did everyone agree this was
the best?
- Wasn't it
Blockbuster videos?
- I don't know, it was...
- Because for me, it played
before every movie at the cinema.
- Yeah, every movie ever had it, yeah.
- Oh, I didn't see it in movies.
- I only know it from the cinemas.
- Oh, I only know it
from like rental stuff.
- Really?
"Twilight Zone"
- Welcome to subject of Trash Taste.
That's a strange topic that we didn't mean
to get on, but welcome.
I'm your host Connor with
the boys, Joey and Garnt.
- Hello, as we've established,
the host means nothing now
as someone on the Trash
Taste, Reddit pointed out.
- I explained to them, I
was like, on my last show,
I was like, listen, you don't understand.
You get power when
you're on the solo seat.
- You get space.
- You do, yeah.
- You do.
- I don't know how to explain it.
You just get like a
feeling that your like,
I'm the host.
- I'm in control.
- I'm in the conversation.
- Like every time when I hosted before
and there was a guest on,
I'm just like, well that's
my hosting privileges gone
'cause I gotta take care of the guest.
I'm on babysitter mode now.
- Now you're in the beta seat.
I hate that seat the most.
- Really?
- I feel like I'm furthest
away from everything.
Hi, guys, hi, host, hey,
like across, you know.
- It's not that bad.
- I know, I know.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
A part of me just feels
like I like these two seats.
- I like that seat.
- I like this seat, too.
(talking over each other and laughing)
- I'm the only one that's
literally never given a (beep).
I'm like, we're still
sitting at the same table.
- Something about it just,
you know, feels different.
- It's differently.
It's like getting like the
front seat in the car, you know?
You are the alpha male.
- What are you, five years old.
- Yes, you are.
- Shotgun!
- Gotta get
- Every time we go on
- the booster seat, too.
- a road trip,
Joey's the one that shotguns
the front seat every (beep)in'
time, I swear to God.
- [Ashley] Appreciate it
because he can read the signs.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I'm doing it for the driver, all right.
- There's more responsibility for me.
You can chill in the back of the car.
- The front seat's only good if the driver
is also really confident because
if the driver's confident
then he's not gonna bother you.
- Yeah, but if the driver's not confident,
then he's gonna bug you.
- Can you look at the map?
Actually, can you change the song?
Can we can stop?
It's like, no,
but if the driver chatty, he's like...
- But even if...
- I drive.
- But even if it's a
confident driver, right,
you're gonna be the one
guy who's like, you know,
someone in the back's gonna be like,
can you turn up the AC?
It's like, fine, I'm (beep)in'
in a hurry, whatever.
- This is why I feel
sorry for any short person
who is on a group road trip, right,
because here's the
thing, here's the thing.
No matter what, no matter what we think,
no matter what we think is
the best seat in the car,
we can all unanimously
agree that the worst seat
is the middle seat in the back, right?
- Yeah.
- And who always gets that?
It's the short person because
they take up the least space.
Cause I can always be like,
look guys, I'm a bit tall.
Can I get at least get
one of the side seats?
And everyone's like, all
right guys, I understand.
I'm just like...
- I love how the people
throw in that argument
as if like the one that
is in the middle seat
has more leg room or something.
We all have the same amount
of leg room, so it's like...
- You're like worrying
about invading two people's
leg rooms as opposed to
just regarding your own.
- Oh, is that the loathe?
- I think so, but also it
doesn't really have to do
that much with height, surely it's...
- Yeah, it's about width, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah
- You could be like...
- What if it's like
Eric Cartman, right?
Eric Cartman is like wider
than he thought, like...
(talking over each other)
- Like where's he gonna sit?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, and for me it's always like
it's it's whoever has
like the smaller stature
that sits in the middle.
- The stature,
- Which a lot of the times
happens to be the shortest person.
- Oh, that's true.
- Right?
- But there are some like short,
thick people out there in the world,
so like where do they sit?
- I'm sure they are, but I'm just saying
every time, because I'm always that person
that forgets like shotgun the front seat,
so I'm just like, if I
can't get in the front seat,
there's no way in hell I'm
getting the middle seat.
- You'll catch me dead
before I'm in the middle seat.
- Yeah, you'll catch me dead
- You'll catch me in the mood.
- Oh, you want me to take the middle seat?
Oh, okay, well, oh I guess these long legs
have no space to sit.
Oh, let me just, let me just,
lemme just man spread as much.
Lemme just man spread as much as possible
so you can regret this decision
of putting me in the middle seat.
- Garnt's polite enough though.
If you're like, Garnt,
get in the middle seat.
Don't be like, all right.
- Yeah.
- But it depends
on the length of a journey.
If it's a short journey, I'm like,
I'll take the middle.
I don't...
- Really?
- Yeah.
Even on a short trip,
I don't want the middle.
- Like an hour in the middle.
I can do an hour in the middle.
- An hour's short?
- Yes.
I'd say like four hours
where it gets like long.
- Four hours, you can
throw me in the trunk, man.
I'll have a better time in there.
- Yeah. I don't know.
Like, it's the middle seat, especially.
It's not just like the least comfortable.
It's just the one that induces
the most motion sickness
for me as well 'cause...
- No, I don't get motion sickness.
- The problem with the middle seat is that
it's always got like the
(beep)tiest seatbelt, right?
Like, what...
- That's the bulk..
- That's the waist-only one, right?
- Yeah, it's it's the waist-only one
so it feels like the top
half just like has less,
what's the word I'm
looking for, like support.
It has less support, right?
You're nice and snug.
- And that
makes you motion sick?
- Kind of like a lot of things make me
motion sick.
- Garnt's one of those people
who literally needs to be like
(beep)in' straight-jacketed
into the seat to be like
no motion sickness for me.
The other thing as well
is a lot of the times
the middle seat doesn't
have a headrest as well.
So a lot part of the thing that helps me
with motion sickness is having
something to rest my head on.
- That sounds like a tall person problem.
- It very much is a tall person problem.
Either I get motion
sickness or I just have like
massive whiplash from just like trying
to lie like this for like two hours.
Then after saying all
of that can you really
fault me for shotgunning the front seat,
clearly so I can avoid (beep)in' sitting
like this for the entire trip, right?
- That's why short people
deserve to be in the middle.
- It is your right as a short person
to take a bullet for the
team, no headrest for you.
- No headrest for you,
you don't need a headrest.
You're short enough as it is.
I need a headrest, okay.
- Garnt hates short people, confirmed.
He wants them all to
sit in the middle seat
for the rest of time.
- This is the birth of heightism.
- Heightism, is that a
thing, is that a thing?
- Maybe, probably, if you're on Tinder.
- You can't call them short.
That's gonna end up being derogatory
at one point of our lives.
- That's true.
- 'Cause everything ends
up being derogatory.
- Also, there's no clear definition
for when somebody becomes short.
- Exactly, right.
- Right.
- Vertically challenged.
That's that's all we have
to start using from now on.
- I hate that, it's so dumb.
- Don't call them short.
- Yeah, at which point?
What is the cut-off for short?
Well, it depends how tall you are.
- Also how self-conscious you are.
- [Ashley] Depends on
where you are as well.
- Some guys say anything below
six foot, you're a dwarf.
- Yeah, but then again, it's like...
- Who says that?
- I say that.
- Insecure men, I think.
They're like...
- It depends.
I think the definition of short
is dependent on like your
point of reference, right?
- Also the country that you are in, right?
If you're from Netherlands.
- Then everyone here is short.
- Yeah, I feel like an average
sized human being in the UK.
And then I moved to like Thailand
and like the toilets come up to my shins.
That's that's that's
like the bigger indicator
of when I go to like
Thailand, I can't remember.
I think Japan's like kind
of the same when I go
into the public toilets and normally like,
it goes up to like my knees.
- Yeah.
- But then the toilets
there go up to my shins.
I'm just like, what, what is this?
What is this country?
- Yeah.
- There's some Japanese high school kids
that are (beep)in' massive.
- Yeah.
- I've noticed.
- Walk on the train.
They'll be like six-foot-five.
I'm like, oh my God.
- I've kind of noticed
that like I feel that
when I first moved here
or even earlier than that,
everyone around me was shorter than me.
But nowadays, like, as you said,
there are like seven feet
tall high school kids.
- It's nuts.
- It's like hat happened?
The entire country just
had like a growth spurt.
- I don't know.
- 'Cause I remember.
I remember, like...
- Anecdotal, but I mean.
- Yeah, no, it's certainly anecdotal,
but I remember at one point
when I was in high school,
'cause I basically, I
reckon I stopped growing
like around 16, 17, right?
- I'm still growing (indistinct).
I'm still growing.
- Are you?
- No, no, I'm not.
- I personally stopped
growing at around like 16, 17,
so right before I graduated high school,
and I remember there
was one time where I was
on an absolutely packed train in Tokyo,
and I was like a (beep)in' Q-Tip
in a field of like cotton swabs.
It was just me and then it's
just like a sea of heads.
But nowadays I'm just like,
I get in a packed train and I'm like,
everyone around me is
the same height as me.
Like what happened?
- Why am I Beta now.
- Is everyone like wearing (laughing)
I thought I was the only one.
- Joey thought he was built different,
but he's built the exact
same as everyone else.
- I was like, I'm exclusively
in the six-foot club.
Now everyone is in the six-foot club.
- Well, aside from Connor.
- Except for Connor.
- Aside from Connor.
As is evident in like every photo we take.
It's surprising about we've
taken this many photos
and we still get the same...
We still get the same three comments
every (beep)in' time which is...
- Asians are taller than white people, no.
- I didn't expect Connor
to be the shortest,
which Connor's not a short guy.
Connor's not short, that's the thing.
- You're not a short dude
(talking over each other)
- I feel like the Mr.
Incredible meme right now.
You guys are like happy.
I'm like the (beep)in' pain.
I'm not short, I'm tall.
I'm 5'10".
- But the thing is, but the
thing is you're not short.
- I don't really...
- Especially in this country.
- Yeah, I don't feel, I don't feel short.
- No.
- Yeah.
- But like you meet people, you're like,
I am tiny on this earth.
- Well, yeah, every time
I go to the Netherlands,
I'm like, oh I am literally
vertically challenged right now
compared to everyone else, but in Japan,
it's like, you know, you meet people
who are like three feet tall
and they're living their lives
normally, so I'm like good.
(talking over each other)
- Your so full, you're
like why are you living?
(background noise drowns out other sounds)
- Is it tough, is it tough?
- Why you, why are you doing this here?
Why, why give up, give up.
- How can you live?
- How is hard mode?
How is hard mode going?
- She had pogos for legs.
- I'm just kidding.
My girlfriend is literally the
shortest person I know, so.
- I don't know I don't really
give a (beep) about height.
I don't know.
- Eh, me neither.
- I think it's one of
those things that people
don't really care about, and
when they do, I'm like why?
- I've met people who are like,
I will only date someone
unless they're like X.
- That's the common thing, right?
- Yeah.
- I'm like, why, why though?
What are the privileges of being taller
than a certain?
- I get it.
- You have a preference,
right, you might like really,
I know guys who love
taller women than them.
They love women that are
taller them, I get that.
- Nothing against that, but like..
- I guess it's the wording, right?
- Yeah.
- Some girls just,
when they word it, I can
understand why it hurts
some of those guys out
there that are like,
I just wanted a break, man,
and then I'm just not six foot,
and I'm like it's all
right, man, it's all right.
Don't worry about it,
don't worry about it.
- I don't get like why
is it just that cut-off?
You know, it's just, I it's, I don't know.
It's always weird to me.
- I'm yet to meet a woman who was like,
man, I want a man who's
at least four feet tall.
It's just every man be
like, thank you, thank you.
Inclusive.
I don't know why.
I think six foot sounds nice.
- Well, what about like 175 centimeters
or something?
- No, doesn't have
the same ring to it.
- 180 centimeters, that's...
I dunno, it's around the same, right?
What's what's six foot again?
- 180, I think.
- 181, something like that.
- Sorry, I don't know.
- I'm exactly six foot, so whatever I am.
- Let's start a new standard in metric.
- Joey's like, phew, just made it.
- [Joey] Yeah, I literally,
I was like just scraped by.
- There is a God.
- I grew two millimeters last year
and I just scraped by, what?
- [Ashley] 183
- I'm not even six foot.
- I always thought I always
thought six foot was 180.
- Joey, you're kinda looking
mighty short right now, Joey.
You're kinda looking
mighty short right now.
- [Ashley] It's technically 182.8, yeah.
- Okay, hold on.
I know what I am in
centimeters, let me ask.
- That's okay, it'll make
your dick look bigger.
- Hey, Siri.
Hey, Siri, (beep)in' Siri, wake up.
Hey, Siri.
What's 181.2 centimeters
in feet and inches?
- .2, throw in the .2.
I'm desperate.
- Shut up.
- I'm desperate.
- She picked up all that.
- [Siri] The answer is 100 over 381.
- That's...
Hey, Siri.
Hey, Siri, what's 181
centimeters in feet and inches?
- Put it put up against the mic.
- [Siri] 181 centimeters is 5.94 feet.
- 5.94, which that's what, 5'11", right?
It's it's not 5'9".
It's 5.94 feet, which is five,
which means it's 5' 11?
How many feet, how many inches in a foot?
- But it's not...
- But it's not six though.
- That's...
- That's all that matters.
- That's the important apart.
- It's not six, which
means you must be six.
- Yeah, I am six.
- Yeah, yeah.
- He's the Chad kid.
- How does that feel?
- You're the real Chad,
Joey, you're the real Chad.
- I thought you were a brother to me.
I thought I was a real Chad, I'm not.
- You could have lied this whole time.
- I could have, I could've just said 183
just to make myself feel better.
- You could've just spent
this whole time lying,
but now you've, now you've outed yourself
as not being confirmed six foot.
- Yeah, it's all right.
- I know, I like my height,
it's a comfortable height.
I see like people taller
than me, and like,
I'm at the height where
there are some things,
especially in Japan where it
just gets a bit inconvenient.
But like, I like some buildings are like,
I need to like, just bob
my head down a little bit.
I can't imagine what it's like
for someone who's like 6'5" or something
like trying to live in Japan.
- Could you imagine having to duck down
every time you go into a train?
- Well, remember that toilet
we went into in that one bar?
We found this toilet in this bar
and I posted a video on Twitter,
but like, it was like a closet.
It was like this tiny little door opened.
And you had to, no joke, like duck down
to like maybe four foot.
- It was like the, it was like
(beep)in' Harry's room and
(beep)in' forced for (indistinct)
- Yeah.
- Where it's under the stairs.
- It was crazy.
- Yeah.
- There's a toilet on the wall.
I thought, the (beep), it looks like some,
like some kind of old 1800s
charcoal storage room.
- Yeah, it was like...
- It was literally like
out of Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs.
That was like...
- (talking over each other) and (beep).
- The room wasn't that small,
the room was quite big.
- Yeah
- It was.
- But the door was comically small.
- But I liked that.
- That was...
- What so you could feel like a Hobbit?
- I don't know, it just looked cool.
- Well, it was unusual.
We're talking about it now.
- It was like the bar in Niseko.
Remember the one where it was like
the fridge door to get in and you had,
everyone had to duck
down to get into that.
- Yeah that was cool though.
- That was cool.
There's something about having a crawl
to just take a (beep).
It's like Shawshank Redemptionesque.
It kinda made me feel like...
- I don't know.
- It wasn't that small.
- It was pretty...
I remember I had to like really...
- It wasn't a hole.
- Like go like this.
Like get in and like.
- Yeah.
- And then I could get in.
I thought that was just like really small.
I don't know, I thought it was like,
is there no regulations
around door sizes in Japan?
- No, apparently not.
- I'm sure in the UK we
have some like kind of rule
that's like the doors...
- Why would there be?
Why would there be?
- Just for like, you know,
'cause maybe it gets to the point
where you're like, all
right, to get to the toilet,
you have to climb through the vent.
By the way, this is a Mission
Impossible themed cafe.
And it's like, ah...
- Well, it depends what
you constitute as a door.
- Yeah, exactly.
What is it, like a cupboard?
- What is a door?
- I felt like there were stretching
the definition of a door.
Yeah.
- The same way like
if I were to open my no, no, no, not my
(background noise drowns
out other sounds) .
Like if you open the fridge,
no that's a fridge door.
- That's a fridge door.
- It's a fridge door.
- It was about the same
height as a fridge door
I would say.
- Yeah,
yeah, I would say so as well.
- Like a small fridge.
- It was just impressive.
I was like, okay, why
not just like knock a bit
of the wall down and make a
bigger door, like there's a...
- I could get what they,
They're just going for like a unique..
- I don't think they would go the bar.
- To be fair, the bar
itself was pretty small.
It was like a, would you
describe it like a diner?
- Like a diner kind of?
There was one bar top and then
there was like two or three,
maybe like two, like three
seater, like bar tops.
- But it looked like
the classic diner seats.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, like the black and white.
- It was just like some random bar
cause we were finding
a place that was open.
But yeah, I don't know why
the toilet fit into the theme.
There was nothing to indicate
it was like a Hobbit theme or anything.
It was really strange, but you find this
in Japan occasionally, just random places
with the weirdest toilets or doors.
- Yeah, 'cause there's a diner in Shobara
that I go to a few times
where the entrance to it
is basically the toilet door.
- Yeah.
- Wow.
Well, it's maybe up to like here for me.
- Oh my God.
- On the street, mind
you on the main street.
- What?
- Yeah.
So people who walk in, you just see people
(beep)in' (audio goes
out) in on the main road.
It's so weird.
- Yeah, you do see some
strange toilets in Japan.
I remember like it's, sometimes
it's just a strange layout
because I remember that one toilet,
I think you also that
tweeted this one out as well,
which is I think we
were like having dinner
with people from Netflix or something.
And there was this toilet in there
that was just in the corner.
And the lighting was like so ominous
that it felt like you would
approach it Jojo-style.
- Oh yeah.
- You remember that?
- It was like diagonal.
- Yeah, it was like diagonal.
- In this room, it was so weird.
- Just leading to this one toilet,
and all the lighting
was just behind this one
this one toilet seat.
- Yeah.
- It's like the toilet
of the promised land.
It's just like, oh.
- Japan has that 'cause I feel like
the restaurant comes first,
then wherever the (beep)
they can fit the toilet and they do it.
- I mean, not that we can really talk.
We have a (beep)ing toilet over there
that's in the corner as well.
- Yeah, that's weird as well.
It's a weird toilet.
- Yeah.
- But I know that there's like um,
oh, (beep), what is it.
Brain, I got...
- Brain.
- [Garnt] Brain commits suicide.
- I forgot what I was gonna say.
Ah, go ahead, talk.
- This episode is sponsored by ExpressVPN.
When you use the bathroom,
you always close the
door behind you, right?
Well, not having ExpressVPN
is like going to the toilet,
but the door is wide open.
Everyone can see you doing your business.
And you don't want people staring in
at your business because did you know
that your internet service provider
knows every single website you visit?
And what's worse is that they
can sell this information
to ad companies and tech giants
who will use your data to target you.
But luckily ExpressVPN is
here to put a stop to that.
It creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device
and the internet so that
your online activity
can't be seen by anyone.
I personally use ExpressVPN
on all my devices.
Obviously, I use it on my PC right here,
but I also use it on my phone, on my iPad,
even on my router.
And the best part is using ExpressVPN
is as easy as closing the bathroom door.
You just fire up the app,
click one button and boom.
You're protected.
Plus ExpressVPN is the
world's #1 ready VPN
Mashable, Diverge and countless others.
So if you're like me and you believe
that your online activity
is your own business, secure yourself.
By going over to
expressvpn.com/trashtaste today.
Use our link, expressvpn.com/trashtaste,
and you can extra three months free.
That's expressvpn.com/trashtaste.
Link's in the description below.
Thanks to ExpressVPN for
sponsoring this episode.
Back to the show.
- How do you guys feel about
just the different like themes
of like the restaurants you find here
because I feel like in Japan,
there are more like you,
there are more ways that
you can find just like
really uniquely done like little cafes
or restaurants more than I've seen in like
basically where I came
from or even London to me?
- I think more so bars,
there's more themed bars
in general.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
- There's a lot of bars.
- Bars and cafes mostly, yeah.
- Yeah, you look at some of
these bars and you think,
how the (beep) do you
stay in business, right,
because some of these bars are tiny.
It's like you think of a
bar, at least in the UK
and America and you think
it's a building, you know.
It's a building with a dedicated room
with tables and chairs,
and that is the bar.
And some of these bars
are just a countertop.
- You're talking about the
one we found the other night?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The one that was literally
the size of a hallway?
- Yeah.
- That was so weird
going into the building.
Do you wanna tell a story?
- Yeah, so we basically, it was after
the really short toilet bar, right.
And we were like, oh, we're feeling good.
So, you know, it's been a
while since the three of us
had like gone out to go
drink and stuff like that.
So we were like, let's go
to this other place in Tokyo
called Yokocho which
has like a lot of like
small hidden bars and clubs
and stuff like that all over the place.
And by hidden, we mean
like there's one road
that is just like covered.
There's like buildings
that have like, you know,
maybe 20, 30 bars in it.
- Yeah.
- Over like six stories
or something like that.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, there were like maybe some like
six to 10-story buildings
and they just had like,
the signs were from the top to the bottom,
all like stacked and...
- It's just like
30, 40...
- Bars, bars, bars, bars.
- So we just like, let's
just go into one of them.
And the one we went into was
like really like pristine
and like very like shiny
and very like chic.
- Which is weird 'cause outside of it,
it looks like a normal apartment building.
- Yeah.
- And like really grimy.
- You get off the elevator,
I think it was on like
the fourth or fifth floor.
You get off the elevator and
it's just this dark hallway.
- It's like yellowish building color.
Like the doors are this horrible...
(talking over each other)
- Any other country that is like a floor
where you would get stabbed.
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
- But yeah, there was like three
or four bars that were open there.
It was just like, let's
just go into one of them.
We went in, it was really pristine,
like silver chic looking thing.
And there was this like
old lady at the end
that was like, you
know, drinking something
really expensive, but yeah,
the size of this place
was maybe what four people
could sit at the bar?
- Yeah.
- I think about six,
'cause I remember there
was a lady on one end
and we were on the other
end and there were like
two seats between us and the lady,
and that's all it could
seat and that's it.
- And the width was literally
the size of a hallway.
- Yeah, exactly.
- If that.
- And they had three
people running this bar
for a bar that can seat six people.
- There were just as many
bar men behind the bar
as there were people sitting at the bar.
- Exactly.
- It was really odd
'cause we walked in there
and it was like this woman,
quite elderly woman in like a kimono
Drinking, like Dom Perignon.
- Clearly like a really important person
or something like that.
- Yeah, and like these
three bartenders were
like all caring for her
like laughing at
everything she was saying.
And then we walked in,
they kind of went like,
"What do you guys want?"
And we sat down like,
"Can we have a beer?"
They were like, "Fine."
And they gave us like a bog-standard beer
from a glass that cost us $20 each.
To be fair though, we did eat like
all of their complimentary snacks.
- Yeah, they put out a lot of stuff.
I don't know what the
(beep) snack that was...
- It was so good.
- But it was so good
whatever it was.
- These weren't like
your average bar snacks.
It was like premium stuff
like dried fruits and stuff.
And every time we ate them
they immediately refilled it.
And I started feeling really
bad 'cause like we must have...
I saw them like opening new packs
and like reluctantly
pouring more snacks for us.
It was a cool bar, but it was just like
the atmosphere was like really weird.
- It wasn't real weird, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
Because then when the elderly woman left,
like two of the bartenders
followed her out
and just...
- Yeah, yeah, yeah!
And didn't come back.
- And never came back.
- They might not even
have worked at the bar.
They might have just been
her personal attendants, yeah.
- Lackeys.
- Two of them, like one of
them was in like a tuxedo.
He was quite elderly as well.
And he looked like, like the
(beep)ing butler from Overlord.
Sebas Tian.
- Sebas Tian
- Literally looked like him
and there was this other guy,
and they left and then we
were like they'll come back,
and they never, never came back.
But they all left at one
point and left us in the bar,
just like alone for like
five minutes and we were like
only in Japan would they leave the bar
with the customers still
in there just to make sure
this like rich customer
can go and do whatever.
- Yeah.
- So strange, so strange.
- It was very weird.
- But like how do you
think some of these bars
do stay in business if they...
- If there are rich
customers that are regulars.
I know there's a big like regular, like,
what's the word?
- Culture?
- Yeah. Yeah.
I think it's very common
to find a bar you like and just only go
to that bar.
- Yeah, yeah.
I like to just constantly bar hop
and just see what else is there.
- Yeah, me too, because like
some of these bars that,
you know, you kind of like
discover like this one,
but this is like one of like basically
every time we go out and
discover a new place.
We go into one of these
kinds of bar where it's like,
every time we go in the
bar is like almost empty
or there's just like that one person
sitting in the corner like
I remember when we went out
with Jan as well, it was
just like the three of us
and one person in the
corner, and it just was
one bartender who I saw.
It's just like, I...
- Chill.
- He's just chill.
He's just enjoying his job,
which is just a delight to see.
And you know, I get it.
That's why like, it's so weird to me
that tipping culture isn't a thing,
and yet bars like this are
able to stay in business
because I can't imagine bars
like this staying in business
if there wasn't a tipping culture, right?
Because the drinks were
expensive, but they weren't like
ridiculously expensive to the point where
one or two people can,
in my mind at least,
run the entire bar economy
and keep it afloat.
So it just, it just,
it just blows my mind.
- Yeah. I have a mate actually
who owns a bar in Saitama.
- Really?
- Yeah, and like,
my hairdresser at the time
was like friends with him
so I got to know him through
that, and he was just like,
and I was just like
curious, 'cause I was like,
how many customers do you get?
'cause it's kind of like
in Saitama, first of all,
which is like far away from Tokyo, right?
So there's less of a population
to, you know, for customers.
But I'm like, it was also in
like a really like hidden area.
Like kind of similar
to the one we went to,
and I was like, how many
customers a night do you get?
And he was like, oh, like
three or four on average.
- Oh my God.
- And I was like, how
long are you open for?
And he is like, oh, like two days a week.
I'm like, and this is your only job?
He's like, yeah, all the other days
that I'm off, I go skiing.
And I was like, how, just like,
where does this money come from?
And he literally just said like
I get three to four customers,
but it's usually the same
three or four customers
that just keep coming back
and are there literally
from bar open to bar close.
- Right.
Just because like they're
his mates and this is like
the only time they get
to hang out with him
while he's working kind of thing.
- Kinda kind cool, but
sad at the same time.
- Yeah, I mean he's
enjoying it and you know,
it's still around and everything,
but it's just like really fascinating
how you can just make that as a living.
- It goes into like the other
aspect of Japanese culture
that is very prevalent where
they, they like predictability.
They like the same thing.
They want to know what's gonna happen
I guess for bar owner and customer.
It's good for that 'cause you get to go
to the same bar every day.
You get to know what you're gonna get.
And then if you're the
owner, it's like great.
I know my customers.
I know they're gonna come and X, X, X.
- Yeah, I do think that like
that's a really cool part
of bar culture in Japan is that you, like,
there are so many small little places
and there's like places that
you would never be able to do
in any other country or at least
in any other country that I've lived in.
Because that kind of business
model just wouldn't work.
You know, you have to have that dedication
of your regular customers, and even...
There has to be like, it's like kinda like
a symbiotic relationship, right,
that the customers
always need to be there.
The customers come back
knowing that they are the ones
that are keeping this bar in business
and they are the only ones,
but I guess what I wanted
to know is like how do you
establish yourself with that?
How do you?
- I think it's literally just
word of mouth at that point.
- The turnover is so fast.
Like I know that restaurants and bars
close and open very fast in Japan.
So I imagine that a lot of
them unfortunately fail.
Like ramen stores are
like incredibly expensive
to start and operate.
- It's also incredibly competitive.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- You can get ramen at any street corner.
- Yeah. And then you
just get destroyed by...
(talking and laughing over each other)
- Yeah, you either get
destroyed by a turnover
like a McDonald's,
- Yeah, yeah.
like one of the mega
corporations, but it's like, yeah.
I don't know.
I literally think it's just like a mate,
like, you know, if one
of your mates is like,
I'm gonna start a bar in X location.
- Yeah.
- You'll be like, oh I'll come
and check it out one night
and then you go tell your mates about it.
And then that friendship forms
and then that symbiotic
relationship forms.
And then if it keeps going
well, it'll keep growing out,
but I mean with how quick it, you know.
- With a bar, is there much
expenses to start out with
apart from obviously getting the location?
I guess all the alcohol.
- All the booze.
- Probably quite expensive.
- Right, you need to
like, I mean the bars,
the bars we went to,
some of them were in like
an apartment building.
They were basically just
someone's apartment, right?
But the way they renovated this bar,
it looks (beep)ing great, you know.
There were so many small
touches in every bar we go to.
So I'm sure a lot of it was
also spent on renovation
just to make it look like a bar.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think we went to two bars that night.
I remember the second one
was a lot more themed,
but the first one was very chill,
very nice.
- Yeah.
And I think they were reasonably priced
because this guy would spend
like 10 minutes making a drink.
- Yeah.
Could he have been faster, yeah probably,
but it was nice watching.
I feel like that's part of the experience
when you're in these cool bars.
Like you just get to
watch the guy just go ham.
Just like do little things, just...
- Make something cool.
- And then I taste it
and I don't really taste
much difference in other drinks,
but that's not the point.
It's that it feels nice.
- It's the experience that you get, like
yeah, he's making it for you.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
(talking over each other)
- Drinking one of the spoons
has like trained my mind into being like
I need to get this drink
as fast as possible.
You mean your like, I order like a mojito
and they'd better be serving
it in a (beep)ing jug
because otherwise this time
I'm waiting to get this mojito
could be used to like drink
something else, you know?
So just going into these bars,
which are more chilled out
is such a like different
but nice experience
'cause you'd only normally
go to these bars in the UK.
If you had like a (beep)
ton of money to spend a lot.
- I also feel you don't go...
I personally don't go into
those bars to get (beep)-faced.
- No, no, you can't really.
- Yeah, which, you can if
you're there long enough
and you're ordering
stuff that's like easy,
but it's, at the same
time, it's like, you know,
if you're gonna pay for that experience
in that like atmosphere,
that chill atmosphere,
then just like go easy
on your drinks, right.
Just go slowly.
- It's kind hard 'cause the
atmosphere doesn't really
make you feel like you're
like drink, drink, drink.
Just take your time.
- Yeah.
- Just take your time.
- Let's just relax, let's just talk.
- This is like really...
- Let's just talk.
- Also really thankful that
I speak enough Japanese
to be able to do those
bars like no pressure.
Those bars don't require that much.
- Yeah.
- I feel like if you...
If there's any reason to learn Japanese,
probably just learn super basic stuff
so you can go to those bars.
If you don't speak any
Japanese, they might be like...
- It's also a really good
place to practice Japanese.
- [Connor] That's true
as well, that's true.
- Because every time I go bar hopping,
I get to speak more Japanese
than I would normally.
And the bartenders are normally, well,
it's kind of their job to
be, way more understanding
and, and come...
- It's their job
to interact with the customers.
- Basically, yeah, exactly.
- If you're gonna talk to a bartender,
they're not gonna be like,
oh, what the (beep)...
(laughing noise drowns out other sounds)
- They might, they might,
but they probably wouldn't.
They're really nice.
I've never been to one of those bars
where the bartender's been like rude
or anything.
- No, no.
- They're always super nice
and like always interested.
- They wouldn't be in
business if they were.
- That's true, at the end of
the day it's customer service.
- If there's only like six
seats, they better be nice
to every (beep)ing customer that comes in.
- They can't pretend to like,
oh, well what was that you were saying?
Like, go to a different customer,
but you are the only one there.
- Yeah, I've had other customers be rude
while I've been in those bars.
- Really?
- I think one time I was with Chris
and we were asking a bar,
and it was also a bar
that made food, and we were
ordering a bunch of foods
'cause we hadn't eaten all day
'cause we were like traveling and filming.
This one woman was like,
'Don't you think you've ordered
'enough food," to like me and Chris,
and we're like never, never enough food.
- [Joey] Shut up.
- We were like, what the
(beep) is wrong with you?
Why would you say that
to someone, (beep) off.
I think she was annoyed 'cause
she was talking with him.
I think she was like flirting with him.
- Right, right.
- Right.
We kept obviously making
him like actually like cook
and do his job, I guess, and
she was like really annoyed.
Every time we order anything,
she'd be like, chh, you know.
I'm like, what's your problem?
Oh my God, leave us alone.
We drank so much.
- [Garnt] She's trying
to get the deed, dude.
- I know she, (beep) off, let us eat!
It's because we ordered kamome, bro.
'Cause we ordering cheese
and stuff off, you know.
Chris was like more kamome.
- So we were drinking so
much, we were getting hungry.
We were like more, more, more, more.
- Imagine trying to give them business.
- I know, I was like (beep) off.
I thought it was so rude, I was like
what the (beep)'s wrong with you?
I was in Kochi I think as well,
cause this really tiny like.
- I bet for her, that's like
the only like, you know...
- Maybe yeah, that's...
- Solace out of whatever she
is living through, right?
- Yeah, I don't know.
Clearly she wasn't very happy,
she wanted take it out on us.
I dunno why, I remember...
- I mean it's Kochi and there isn't
a whole lot else to do there.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, there's not much
going on, (beep) you.
I don't know, it was a nice bar though.
I remember that it was like
an Irish bar or something
that's the theme of it, right?
- What?
- Right.
It was really good though
'cause they did like,
they had Heineken on tap.
- Oh, (beep).
- And I just drank like, and it was...
They had actual pints of Heineken.
- Ooh, okay.
- I was like, this is amazing.
And I drank way too much 'cause I was like
so excited to finally
have a real sized pint.
I was like, oh, my God,
it was good though.
Amazing.
Sorry, random tangent.
- Random tangent.
- That's fine.
- You guys then been any other
like weirdly themed bars?
I mean I know you have for
a bunch for your videos
and stuff.
- Yeah.
- Or like just outside of that.
- A lot of the cool bars,
I wouldn't want to go film anywhere.
I'd just wanna kind of do it.
Like there's that bar we went to.
It's like this bar that's
like, I don't, I won't say,
'cause I don't want it
to become like brammed,
But it's like they have
like live music there
and that was really cool.
- Oh, really?
It was like dude playing piano, cello,
I don't know, violin, and double bass.
- Oh, that one.
- The jazz ones.
- Kinda like a jazz bar.
There's like, and it's
there's like the whole wall
is just like wine.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
I remember that one.
- It was really cool.
- And they have like cigars
and like the atmosphere's very chill.
- That sounds nice.
- Cool, yeah.
It's super awesome,
these dudes are amazing.
It's super chill just being there
- Yeah, I really miss going to a bar
that has live music 'cause like all...
- When it's good as well, you're like,
'cause sometimes when
you've got live music,
you're like (sucking
air through his teeth).
- Yeah, it's like, when the
music's not too in your face.
- Yeah, well if it's too loud, I...
- Yeah, yeah, sometimes you go to a bar
and the music, the music, like,
the music is way too aggressive
that you can't focus on
anything else but the music.
- Yeah.
- Like this bar is just perfect.
The music was just like,
you can have a conversation
or you can just like admire this guy
like tearing it up on like
the trumpet or saxophone,
or whatever he was playing with the piano.
They were (beep)ing insane.
- Really cool.
Really cool.
And you can actually tip them.
They had a tip jar.
Yeah, I assume that's how they make most
of their money there,
but it's really cool.
It was really awesome.
- Yeah.
- But you get charged for
just like sitting down
for like the music charge.
- Oh, yeah.
- Like $20.
But they're playing for like three hours.
- Yeah, I mean if the
music's good, why not?
- Yeah, it's really (beep)ing good.
So cool.
- I used to go to so many of
those places in Australia,
but like they all just
got (beep)ing replaced
by like just standard, like
poker machines and (beep)ing...
- What's the Australian bar culture like?
- Um, I'd say pretty similar to the UK
in the sense that you go in,
you have, you know, some food,
you know, beers and what
not, and then you watch
the footy on the TV kind of deal,
you know?
- Yeah, 'cause like to me,
like would you count a pub as a bar?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
It's not the same, but it
is in definition still.
- I guess it's...
- The OG.
- It fulfills the same.
- It's the OG.
It's the OG Bar.
- It's only since I've
moved out of England
that I've considered a pub a bar, right,
Because before like, I mean, I get it.
It's a place that you go to drink.
But to me, like a pub
always felt different,
in the UK at least, to a bar, you know.
A pub's somewhere where most
of the time you go there
to drink, but you know,
you can just have like
a nice Sunday lunch.
You can have like a nice breakfast there,
whatever as well.
- Yeah.
- A bar was always like
somewhere you would go
before going to a club,
or somewhere where you are
100% of the time...
- Like spend the night there.
- Getting (beep)-faced.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
A pub you can go to like
in the daytime as well.
I could never like imagine having gone
to a bar before 5:00 PM, you know?
- Right, right, or yeah,
I guess in that sense
then a pub is more so
similar to Izakaya in Japan
in that instance, whereas like a bar
is just like live music.
- People drinking.
(talking over each other)
- Most people normally go
to, at least in the UK.
I've, hmm.
- - See because for us,
it's like everyone eats at the pub.
- I wanna say like 70% of people
don't eat when they go to the pub.
- Really?
- Yeah.
I think the older you get,
the more likely you are to eat at the pub.
- Oh, yeah, that, yeah, that's true.
That's true, that's true.
- I think it's just a thing.
'cause the older you get, the
more you wanna on weekends,
you wanna go hang out with your mates.
- Yeah, that's true.
- Oh, yeah
You wanna go meet down for a Sunday,
at the, yeah, yeah, maybe, I
don't know, but I like pubs.
Pubs are interesting in the UK
'cause it's one place where, you know,
it's also a (beep)hole.
It's also a (beep) ton of
historical significance
to some of these pubs.
- Yeah.
Some pubs have been around
for like 800 years in the UK.
Isn't it insane?
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's insane.
Just some guys pouring drinks
that have been there for like 800 years.
- Yeah, it's like four times
the length of Australia.
- Isn't that insane?
Like there are like
pubs that are still open
that have been around for
like, like 500 plus years.
- That's crazy.
- Maybe not the same name,
but like the location is
the, it's just insane.
Yeah, and you go in and it's
depressing most of the time.
- Well, because it's been around
for like 500 years, right?
- Not much has changed.
- I don't know, pubs
are one of those places
where it very much reflects the
local area, the state of it.
- The state.
- Absolute state.
- You go into the pub and you're like,
all right, we're going on.
- If the community's doing
well, the pub will be nice.
It's true.
- Everyone's happy.
The pub is nice.
- That's true.
- Yeah, that's true.
- If it's an area that has been like
kind of forgotten by the government...
- Shankings every week.
- You know, it's kind of,
- you know, it's a reflection.
I don't know the pub scene,
it's where you get to see the actual,
I'd say culture of the actual place
really is probably the most
honest way to find out about
the culture.
- I'd agree with you.
It's like if you wanna see
what proper British people
are like you go to pubs,
you go to pubs, right?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- You'll see that there's a difference.
Well, I mean, I remember
before whether the image
was different, but now, you know, if you,
it's, it's not all just like
either, how can I word this?
It's not that we're either
like prim and proper people
or just whatever the (beep)
we're getting clowned on
on the internet.
- I remember when I went
to the UK and you took
me to that gaming pub.
- I don't know...
- Ohhh!
- Don't put that all on
me, we both took you.
- I mean, yeah, you both took...
- No, I'm pretty sure it was Connor's idea
to bring you to that gaming pub.
- Connor's like I know a place.
- I think it was supposed to be chill,
but I think that day specifically
it was 'cause the Overwatch World Final.
- Yeah. The Overwatch
World Finals was happening.
- Really (beep) 'cause it was
so busy and you could get on.
- But even, even before
the actual final started,
we got there a little bit early
before the finals actually
started so we could at least
get a few drinks in then
chill and everything.
And I was like in my head, you
know, I was like, oh, okay.
A gaming pub in the UK, all right.
I wonder what they have.
They just had a Wii on the window sill.
A single Wii with Smash, that's it.
- And five PCs.
But the PCs were all taking out
'cause of the Overwatch finals.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I'd never been
unironically oy oy oyed before
until that night when I
was like sitting outside
'cause the Overwatch
Finals are happening inside
and it was like way too loud
and I didn't really care.
So I sat just 'cause there
were a couple seats outside.
Yeah, and this dude clearly
like about six pints in
just literally came up,
sat next to me, was like,
oy oy oy?
- Yeah.
(laughing and talking over each other)
Yeah, that happens in the UK.
- I was like, wow, you exist.
- I think I was playing in an
Overwatch tournament that day.
I think, was it that day, yeah, I was.
- I think it was that day.
- Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you were.
- I think you signed up.
- Yeah, you did.
- I did.
- You did sign up.
- It was like the winner got a free drink.
Yeah.
It was like a six-round tournament.
- Yeah.
I think I won the first four matches.
Yeah.
- But then the fifth match,
I was like six beers deep.
- Yeah.
- And so it was starting
to get a lot harder
to win these wimpy ones at Overwatch.
And then the guy, I remember
I got so annoyed, I was like,
the guy I'm going against,
he was just drinking coffee.
And I was like, how is this fair?
I'm six drinks deep.
And this guy he's just
drinking a (beep)ing Starbucks.
of course I'm gonna lose.
I can barely like (beep)ing
sit in the chair correctly
and I didn't get my free drink.
I lost, I was very salty.
I think he was like a (beep) rank as well.
I could have easily have beat him.
It could have been easy, it's not right.
- Yeah, I do notice that
about it's especially like
themed bars in the UK, because like UK,
like the UJ bar-themed bar game
is (beep)ing weak as (beep).
I dunno if it's changed
ever since I moved,
but like, you know, like you...
- Back in my day.
- You have a gaming bar in the UK, right?
And the gaming bar in the
UK, as Joey has just said,
is just like a Wii in
a corner and four PCs.
- And the stickiest Wii motes
I've ever touched in my life.
- I was like, ahhh.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Is that shut down now?
- It might be, I dunno, I can't remember.
I can't remember.
- Real quick before I lash out.
- Yeah, yeah.
Let me make sure they're
not in business before I...
- What was it called again?
I can't remember what it...
- Meltdown.
Meltdown, oh, that was it!
- Meltdown?
- I think that was shut down.
- It is closed.
I think it's closed and it
keeps reopening and closing.
Right.
- Okay.
It was quite gritty though.
- Yeah.
- It was all right.
- I mean, I still had a good time.
- It was better than nothing.
- Yeah.
- It was better than
nothing, but you compare it
to some of the gaming bars
and some of the theme bars
you find...
- Some of the gaming bars
in Tokyo are like...
- Yeah, yeah.
- In the UK, they do have a new one now.
I remember...
- Is it good?
- I went there.
- It's called the Meltdown.
- No, it's called, ah,
I think the one now's
called Platform I think.
But it was very expensive, like
to go on the PC it was like,
oh God, it was like paying
normal computer costs,
like computer cafe costs in London.
Like five pound for an hour maybe?
- Right.
- Or maybe 30 minutes.
It might have been five
pounds for 30 minutes.
- Yeah.
- It's like $7.00
And you weren't allowed to take
your drink up obviously,
but that just kind of sucks.
- See, but like that
sounds like a gaming bar
where the gaming takes
priority over the bar, right,
whereas Meltdown was definitely
like 92% bar, 8% game.
- The thing I liked Meltdown
was that it was just,
I don't know, it was just
kind of like comfy, you know.
- Yeah, it was comfy.
- Yeah.
- You could do anything in that bar.
You could like order food
from like the local pizza
place and eat it at that bar.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was a cool place to
chill out, but in terms
of just like having like a cool themed bar
where like, you know, a lot of effort
has gone into like the
theming and the vibe.
I mean, I've been to bars in America.
I've been to bars in
like, you know, in Japan.
And you know, for example,
you have like an anime themed bar.
You have like a Jojo themed bar in Japan.
And like, you can tell.
You walk in and immediately it's just like
you're transported to like
a theme park, you know?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Thought has gone into like
the aesthetic, the vibe, the design.
And then you go to like
an anime bar in the UK
and it's a pub with a
docu-marker in the corner.
That's basically like,
that's what I remember.
Like that's the absolute state
of themed bars in the UK.
- Mind you, I still had a fun time.
I'm saying all this (beep) about Meltdown.
I still had a good time.
- No, it was a fun time,
but it wasn't exactly,
it wasn't exactly a gaming bar.
Let's just say that.
- That's the thing about UK bars.
We have fun there, you have fun.
- We have fun. You have fun.
- You have fun.
- It's just not what you're expecting.
- There's another one.
I don't think we took you there to,
a board game bar, but it all
also has video games, right?
- Right.
- Yeah.
- You told me about it, but we decided
not to go to it for whatever reason.
- It's kind of far out the way.
We went there.
I remember we went there, the other,
when I went back to the UK
recently just for a drink
and it was Rock Band night.
- Right.
- And it was rough.
- Really?
- Because people were singing.
Anyone's allowed to sing.
- That's basically a karaoke bar.
- Kind of karaoke, but I don't know why
Rock Band makes people worse singers,
but it was like, I remember it was rough.
I remember I was there.
I was like, oh, you know,
I'm not one to judge singers,
cause I'm (beep) myself, but I was like,
this is, this is hard to drink with.
This is like Wedding Singer vibes.
Even worse than that.
- Oh my God.
- It was.
- Yeah, I think just the
problem with having themed bars
in the UK especially is
that if you are going
for like a more delicate
theme, that requires more,
you know, that requires more
thought and more precision
is that you have to make
everything drunk-proof
and not just drunk-proof,
but just like UK-people drunk-proof.
That's like a much higher level.
- Chaos-proof.
- This board game bar had a bouncer.
So that, that should tell you how much,
like this state of the UK,
the absolute state, like
a board game bar, right,
Where you would think that, you know,
us nerds would go, right,
we're like chill, right?
We need a (beep)ing bouncer for it.
- It's like, hold it right there.
What's your top score on Scrabble?
- Sort of that you got a
mortgage that property, mate,
Gotta stop you right there, you
broke our Monopoly, get out.
- Have you finished your
Monopoly game, you can go, man.
- We got someone stabbed over
a game of UNO the other night,
you know, like.
- I gotta do a pat down real quick.
- Yeah..
- Yeah, it's kind sad.
You're like, like what's wrong with us?
Why can't we just
(beep)ing be (beep) for...
- I've heard there's a lot of really fun
board game bars in Tokyo.
I've never been to any of them,
but I know of a couple
that I wanna to go to.
- There's a few in London, actually.
- [Ashley] There's one
new gaming bar in, in Juku
that actually just (speaking off mic).
Well there's one next
to the Arosa bar, right?
Arosa Cafe in Akihabara, yeah.
There's a board game bar there.
- Problem is you need
one that you'd kind of,
if you can't read Japanese,
you need be somewhat familiar
with the game.
- Yeah, sure
- But that's fine if
you know a lot of them
or you have someone who can explain.
- Yeah, yeah.
Most of these games, I'm like,
I don't wanna read the manual.
I'll play it with someone who knows.
They can just explain.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, that's much better.
- Yeah, like if there is
anyone living in the UK
that just does legitimately
go to a cool themed bar,
please, I would actually like to know
if the UK, bar game has improved
since I've moved out of the UK.
- I'd love that, too.
Because like, yeah,
compared into what's
available internationally,
it is, it is weak.
I will say that, it is weak,
but I mean, I understand it.
- Yeah.
- Why, hello, you lovely listeners
and watches of the podcast.
It is I, Joey, your boy.
And I'm here to tell you about
the lovely sponsor for today.
Bokksu.
Bokksu here makes such a
perfect and memorable gift
for anyone in your life who appreciates
Japanese snacks and culture.
Especially during a time
when people aren't able
to travel around as easily as they could.
And this being the month of February,
it is the season of love and
Bokksu here's got you covered
with all of these sweet snacks to share
with your special and loved ones.
For example, why not try this
Hokkaido white raspberry,
a beautiful combination of
rye, rice and puffed corn
coated in that Hokkaido
signature white chocolate.
And don't worry if you're
not too much of a sweet tooth
because you can wash all of it down
with some beautiful organic Hojicha.
But you know what the most amazing part
about this whole thing is,
is not just the fact that you
can get these amazing snacks.
But if you use our code TRASHTASTE10,
you can actually get 10%
off your subscription.
So go and get yourself
or a special loved one
a Bokksu this February.
Thank you to Bokksu for
sponsoring the video.
Back to the show.
- I watched more anime.
- I did, too, actually.
- What did you watch?
- I watched "Attack on Titan."
- Oh, me too, me, too.
- What is going on now?
- Joey's watched as Joey's
only, and first anime.
- You can't just drop this
bombshell on me, guys.
- I tweeted.
- Watch anime.
- I tweeted about how the
first two episodes were wild.
and then I immediately silenced...
- Yeah, you gotta mute it.
- I muted it, didn't see it at all.
But I guarantee all
the comments, all like,
"You don't watch anime."
- Well after this episode
comes out, I think episode six.
- Something like that.
- Yeah.
- Only 12 episodes this season.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
(talking over each other)
- Yeah, it's ending.
- I had to go back a couple of episodes
just because it really does
just like throw you in.
- Well, I mean, it is just
a continuation, right?
- Right, right.
I think I'd completely
forgotten about that.
I was like, oh, it's just
the new season, right?
So I was like, I was
waiting for like the recap.
And I was like, where is it?
Where is it, what's happening?
- Because like not now
anime has this thing
where they call things seasons
but they're really not (beep)ing seasons.
Like it's just parts.
- It's Final Season, Part Two.
- Yeah, right?
- Wasn't there a Part Two of Season Three?
- Yeah, there was a Part
Two of Season Three as well
- So Season Three, Part
One, Season Three, Part Two,
and then Final Season, Part
One, Final Season Part Two.
- Cause like the last season
wasn't really a season
'cause it was just a story that was cut
right in the middle of the story, right,
so I wouldn't really call
that like a full season.
So this was just like the continuation
of the Attack on Titan season.
- I completely forgotten
about that when I started
the first episode of Part Two.
- Yeah.
- So weird to (beep)ing say that.
- I hate that.
- Final Season.
- When I started episode
one, Final Season, Part Two.
- Final Season, the actual final season.
- Yeah, the actual final
season supposedly, but yeah.
- Jajar looks pretty good this season.
Jajar looks pretty good this season.
- It's all right.
- It isn't even that bad actually.
The attacks have gotten a lot better.
- Yeah.
- In CGI.
- I dunno what people...
- I haven't actually
the new Attack on Titan season.
- I dunno if I'm just being
like, I'm just used to it,
but yeah, I think the CGI Titans
look a lot better than they
did in the previous seasons.
- I didn't really notice it
until I saw on Twitter that
people were complaining about.
I was like...
- Oh, well, you know.
They complain about anything CGI.
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
- They feel like detectives.
I saw it, I found the CGI, I did it.
- Yeah, I saw part.
- If you cross reference the manga panel
that they took this from.
- Like I saw a guy on Twitter
complaining about the CGI
in Part Six of Jojo as well
the other day where he was literally like,
I dunno who it was, where I saw an image
where it was like side-by-side comparison.
- I saw this one.
- Like arrows of just like,
this is Part Five, and
this is how many CGI things
are in the background,
and this is Part Six
and this is how many CGI things
there are in the background.
And I'm, we are getting to like
the (beep)ing always sunny
Charlie meme at this point.
Like, you know, it like
I can't comment on the Attack
on Titan Final Season CGI,
but it wasn't too bad.
Why do people do that?
- Part One.
- People just hate CGI,
they're just like the 2D style
I get it, you know, obviously
I would prefer the 2D,
but I don't I wouldn't use any
sleepover CGI being included.
I'm not...
- Yeah,
I don't really care.
- I mean, does it affect the story?
- No.
- Or the impact of the story?
- I get more annoyed when
they just don't even animate stuff.
Like I think there was
a fight in the previous
Part One Final Season that
I wish they'd animated.
- Wait, what?
(talking and laughing over each other)
- The Final Season.
- Which part?
- The Final Season, Part
One, there is a fight in it
that I wish that they'd
actually done something with,
but they just kind of
didn't show anything.
They kinda like cut to the aftermath.
That's when I'm like, well, that's (beep).
I'm like, show me something.
Even if it's CGI, I'd love to see it.
- Perhaps something to do with Levi.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Okay.
I know the moment you're thinking of.
- That one was kind of disappointing.
- Yeah. (talking over each other)
- Show anything, that's where I'm like,
okay, this is (beep) when
they're not even showing
the fight.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's when it bothers me.
- The only thing I would say that I think
has been a step down is that the story
of Attack on Titan Final
Season has been amazing,
but compared to like what
previous seasons did,
there wasn't like that epic
oh my God fight moments.
- Yeah.
- I feel like that's the only
thing that's really missing
from this final season
or that has been missing
because like, there are
some amazing action moments
in the previous seasons and this one
has just been amazing for the
story and for the conflict.
- I look forward less and
less for the action scenes
and more so what's gonna
happen, whereas, you know,
like Season Three, Part One
had that glorious scene,
which you've probably seen
all over 'cause the gifs
are like (talking over each other).
- Yeah, the Levi one.
- That (beep)'s insane.
Like anything involving
Levi is just like...
(talking over each other)
- It was kinda interesting.
So I remember when that
came out, you know,
everyone was like joking
that Attack on Titan
Season Two was so boring.
- Yeah.
- That scene came out in Season Three.
- Part One, Part One.
- Yeah, Part One, and everyone
was just like a Attack
on Titan hype again.
Everyone was like that one scene
made everyone hype for Attack on Titan.
So it was so well done, it was insane.
- Yeah.
- I mean, there were even like some scenes
in Season Two though, like
(beep)ing incredible as well.
- People just didn't care 'cause
it took five years, right?
Or like four years.
- Yeah, it took like,
yeah, five, six years?
- It was also the point.
it was also the point where
the story started to get like,
had like the political side of it all
like in the story and the world...
- [Connor] Yeah, Season Two was slow.
- So it was a lot harder for
people to get like hyped over.
They were gonna be like, yo
politics, hype, you know,
they wasn't gonna.
- I think that's just
because it was like so
different from Season One
because Season One was just like,
it was so fast-paced and so
action packed that people like.
- It was so cut and dry and
like straight to the point.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Of like
this is what's happening.
You're gonna get hyped for this fight,
this fight, this fight, this fight.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm glad they slowed it down in Season Two
and literally like
built up the characters,
built up as well because now I think
it's so much better for it.
It's like a much...
- It's like a payoff show.
for like the action scenes now
has just become like so much greater
even though part the Final
Season, Part Two right now
there isn't really any like
fight scene that's made me go,
I mean, I've only seen
the first two episodes,
but like there hasn't been a fight scene
that's made me go like,
yo or anything like that.
- Everything's a fight right now.
- If anything, the one thing
that's been talked about
is that (beep)ing face, right?
- [Connor] Oh my God, yeah.
- Mean (beep).
- I don't even know the
context of that face.
I've I've seen it like on my timeline.
- That caught me off guard.
- That caught me off guard as well, yeah.
I was like, whoa.
It's like a horror anime
now, what the (beep)?
- I guess it'll be interesting to see
how our opinions change when it's over
and to see our final thoughts on it.
That would be interesting.
- Yeah, that would be interesting.
- Following it now for
like, I don't know, six...
- Do you think, do you feel
like this is the anime that has
like just defined this modern
generation of anime fans?
- Yeah.
- This is gonna be the show
for the next 10 years that when
someone was like, well I wanna
watch anime, what do I watch?
I watch Attack of the Titans.
- You go back on the
greats of the two thousands
and it's like, well Attack
on Titan, obviously,
- you know?
- Yeah.
- It is, like as much
people wanna be like,
no it's (beep), whatever
'cause they wanna have like
a counter opinion, like, no it is,
it is a good show.
- It's a great show.
- In this generation.
- I'm interested to see
how the ending is gonna go down because
whether it is good or
not, 'cause I don't know
'cause I'm not a mind reader,
whether it's good or not,
the anime community is
probably gonna explode
one way or the other,
right, through discussion.
- I don't know how I've
like (beep)ing dodged
all these spoilers, I don't know anything.
- Yeah, because whenever you even like
utter the word Attack on Titan ending,
all the (beep)ing mongerators
come out of the shadows
like war veterans being like, ah...
You'll soon see one of these...
- All I know is it's divisive.
That's good, that means
it's gonna be interesting.
- Yeah.
- I'm excited.
'Cause if everyone
agreed, like it's decent,
I'd be like (beep).
Now that I know it's divisive,
I know that I'm I'm in for something good.
- Yeah.
- I'm like preparing a nuclear shelter
for a (beep)ing Twitter that's...
When the ending comes
out I know that Twitter
is gonna be like a (beep)ing
landmine, you know.
- Oh, yeah, definitely.
- [Connor] I'm hyped, I'm
hyped for it, I'm hyped.
- Any opinion will be shattered
by the opposite party.
- It's gonna be one of those
shows where you just need
to watch it just so you
can have a take on it.
You know like your personality
is going to be defined
on whether you on what take you have
on the Attack of Titan...
- Match.com will be asking what you felt
about the ending of Attack on Titan.
- So my credentials for
a boyfriend over six feet
thought the ending of
Attack on Titan was good.
If you don't fit these, get out.
- That's how you know,
man, it'll be interesting.
I'm really, really hyped,
and also it's probably
the longest anime that
I've been following, right.
It's like, okay, it's finally
like an end is in sight.
And like an actual ending,
not a oh they (beep)ed up
the production, oh, it's gone
now, it's never coming back.
It's like an actual wrap
up of a long running thing.
- Yeah, I can't even remember
the last time I experienced
something like this where I
was just watching an anime
and it was like, it just ended
and I had to wait years for it to end.
Actually, I know it's even (indistinct),
but aside from that, I
just realized it's just...
(talking over each other)
- I wasn't there from the start.
- That's what I'm saying.
Like for me, it's like,
'cause I've been there
from like the beginning,
- You've lived through this.
- I'll lived through
- the initial hype, every single phase
of Attack on Titan hype and
controversy and everything.
I've been through it all.
So having it come to an
end is gonna feel so weird
'cause even like, if you
were like, all right,
well One Piece, yeah,
but One Piece was around
before you were around, right?
- Started in '96, '98?
(talking over each other)
Like imagine if you're like a 50-year old
Japanese salary man who's
been reading One Piece
since your 20s, it must
be like really weird
to think that one day it's gonna end.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Unless you've been around
forever and conscious around
every single phase of it.
- That's what a bunch of
50-year old salary men
were like when Naruto ended, right?
- Yeah, true.
- They were like,
like bleach, right, it
was like, oh, my God.
- It was crazy.
- (Beep)in' over.
- I don't know. Like
to me Naratu ending got
so soured by the fact
that Boruto, I think,
was like announced rightly
even like before it ended.
So I'm just like, well it's
an ending, I'm emotional,
but I know it's not really ending...
- 'Cause there's more of it.
- Cause like there's already more of it.
- Yeah, that's true.
- I wish I could go back
and watch Death Note,
like what episode one,
through like 30 seconds,
- Just log onto Twitch.
- I know I oh, (laughing and
talking over each other).
Hunter as well,
but like going in...
- Join the anime...
- Could you imagine if you
were around when Death Note
was, if it was an anime only,
and it was like week by week.
Holy (beep), that would have been crazy.
I wish I was there.
- I was there during
the second half of when
the manga was serializing.
- Yeah.
- And even that was (beep)ing crazy
'cause like it obviously started
before I started reading Shonen Jump.
So I had to like do a quick
catch up to like keep up
with everyone, and even then
that was (beep)ing crazy.
- Only imagine the levels of hype
that it would have reached nowadays
if something like that dropped today.
- Yeah, it was weird because
I was one of the guys
who was watching like
Death Note when it aired,
and it was just a different
vibe because rather than people
discussing it weekly, you just had people
be like, watch Death Note, it's amazing.
So you could only get like
discussions of the entire show
after it had finished.
- Right, right.
- As opposed to, yo, did you
catch the newest episode?
(Beep)ing...
- Yeah.
I letter got removed from the alphabet.
Well, that was (beep)ing insane, man.
- This is true though.
I wish I could have been around
with something like that.
It's so, I guess, I don't
know what the next show is
that's gonna be like
that one, I don't know.
Maybe Mushoku Tensei, I don't know.
Maybe.
- I hope so.
I mean...
- It's a hard shoe to
fill just because it's,
you very rarely see anime
that literally appeals
to everyone and has everything
that everyone likes.
- Yeah.
- Everything is...
- I do hope the next one is Mushoku Tensei
because they literally created a studio
just to make this one show,
but they kind of need to
because of how long the story is.
It follows like his entire life.
- How many episodes do you think?
- Probably need like six seasons.
- Six seasons, that's not that many
compared to like One Piece or something.
- That's true, that's true.
But like, in terms of that
many high quality episodes,
that's like a lot.
- Right, right, right.
That's true, too.
- It feels like more like an autobiography
or like a biography of
a fictional character
kind of like you guys ever seen,
like Boyhood, or that movie?
- Ah, that sounds so familiar.
- That was an movie that
like took 15 years to make
because it basically is
the story of this kid
and how they did it is
that they filmed every year
for 15 years, I think.
- That's pretty cool.
- Yeah.
Yeah, so they, yeah, do you remember that?
I think, didn't it win an Oscar?
- You'd (beep)in' hope so.
- Yeah.
- After 15 years.
- Yeah, it was sort of a lot.
Was it Boyhood, I can't
remember if that was...
- [Ashley] Boyhood, there was
a movie like that with it.
- Yeah, now you can just go on YouTube
and watch those family
channels just raise their kids.
- I watched (indistinct).
- I can just, who needs that now?
That groundbreaking thing
has now been turned into ad revenue.
So now a compelling piece of media
is just film farmed on YouTube.
- Why condense it into
a feature-length film
when you could make multiple seasons
of that (beep)?
- So much more ad revenue
if you're doing, you
know, day by day uploads.
You know, my kid (beep)
himself vlog, you know.
- Like episode 4700.
- If you don't seen those, they're like
the kid gets called up by the
principal and they film it.
They're like filming picking
the kid up from school
after he's been like kicked out of school.
It's insane.
- No.
- That (beep) is insane.
- Family vlog channels are so weird to me.
- It's the most scariest
part of the internet for me.
That's what scares me.
- I can't imagine.
It scares me because I can't imagine.
I mean, it's the complete opposite of like
a healthy environment to
raise children in, right?
- I know it's awful.
- Imagine you're a kid and
you are just like growing up,
just thinking that
everything you're gonna do
is gonna be filmed and you
have to like permanently
be on entertaining mode.
- Oh my God.
We are only years away from
like the first influencer
who was raised in an
influencer, like, house.
- Yeah, you know what I mean?
- I mean they're probably all ready born.
- Yeah, as in like,
what I'm saying is like,
there's probably, there
must be one of those kids
on one of those family
channels that's gonna be like
the first big like YouTuber or something
where his whole entire
life has been documented
willingly, awful.
- Yeah.
- Awful, awful, just not black
mirror (beep) right there.
- Yeah, it really is.
- Literally just Truman Show
right.
- It is Truman Show.
- Terrifying, terrifying stuff.
The kid is raised, not, not, not on his,
what he should be taught in school,
but how to use Google
Analytics and Google Trends.
What a terrifying thought,
what a terrifying thought.
Awful.
- So scary.
What did you wanna say, Ashley?
- [Ashley] What do you wanna
know about Boyhood, it won...
- How long did it like take to make.
- 2002 to 2013, so.
- So 11 years.
- 11 years.
I know it got like canceled,
almost got canceled
'cause the cast members just
wanted to stop doing it.
Like imagine being tied to
a project for like 11 years
and having to do this
one thing every year,
even though you never know
if the film is gonna be
even be finished and released.
- I mean that's, yeah,
that's 'cause like 11 years
is literally, you know, a
kid just starting school
to almost graduating school.
That's a long time.
- Yeah, I mean.
- Especially for a kid.
- Yeah, that is the
entire point of the movie
'cause you literally get
to see this kid grow up.
- Oh my God.
- A lot of it wasn't scripted.
A lot of it, I might be talking my (beep),
but like I think I had a rough plan,
but because they didn't know
what would happen in life.
Sometimes they had to change
the script every year,
depending on what happens,
so I mean, I highly recommend
you guys watch it, it's
a (beep)ing amazing film.
- Sounds good.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, because like it's rare to see
a project that lasts for a long time
and you get to see the
end of that project.
I think some some things
like Attack on Titan
is such a rarity that we
should cherish it whenever
we do get to see something like this.
- I guess I had a normal anime weekend
cause I also watched the
new season of Demon Slayer.
- Ah.
- Oh yeah, how is that?
I've been meaning to start it.
- It's so good, it's crazy, man.
So I watched the movie
right before I watched the new season,
and the animation in the season
was like way better than the movie.
- Really?
- I'm not kidding.
- Yeah.
I was watching the trailer thinking,
waiting for some like insane, you know,
movie budget animation kick in.
And I was like, oh it's not
really that much different
from the episodes.
- I would say the last fight
scene was pretty crazy though.
- It was pretty good.
- The last fight scene was...
- But nothing like that
- they didn't already do in the TV show.
- I guess, yeah, the bar
of quality was pretty high.
- I don't know who's in
charge of the animation there,
but holy (beep), how do
they even step it up more?
Like there was a...
- Man discovers Euphoria Tape.
(talking and laughing over each other)
- There is another level.
- Yeah, I know.
It was just like how do
they keep doing this?
How do they keep getting away with it?
- It's like Mapper as well.
Like every year they
just step it up somehow.
- Generally the new season of
Demon Slayer is really good.
And I hate to be that
normally guy who's like,
yo, I just heard of this amazing anime
(background noise drowns out other sounds)
It's good, it's really good.
- Yeah.
- Really (beep)ing good.
- I've been meaning to start it just
'cause I did actually finally
get around to watching it,
you know, after all those years.
And I really enjoyed it, yeah.
It's ironic, I wanna watch it.
- I haven't seen the new
season of Demon Slayer,
and it's one of those
shows where I'm just like,
I'll watch it when I
feel like watching anime
with no pressure to like make
a (beep)ing video about it.
- Yeah.
- You'll know.
- Yeah, because like to
me, like Attack on Titan
and Demon Slayer, everyone
always knows these shows.
I don't need to make another
video about them yet.
- Think about it, the effort.
(talking over each other)
Come on, it wraps up,
gotta do another attack.
- I'll do I'll do
another one when it ends.
- You have to.
And then that'll be it.
I think I've made like
(beep)ing four videos.
- Attack on Titan is still a masterpiece.
- I can't form an opinion
unless Garnt also agrees with it
(talking over each other) on
his video about it, you know.
If he says it's a masterpiece,
it's a masterpiece.
- I think that's a strong
nine to a light 10, you know.
Like okay, there we go.
- I mean, would you
say Demon Slayer, like,
would you say it's as
good as the first season
or is it like even better?
- When did the last season come out?
How many years ago is that now?
- 20...
- 2019.
- Right before we moved
to Japan then, right?
- Was it 2019, I thought
it was before that.
- 'Cause I feel like,
(talking over each other)
like I'm forgetting, but
I feel like it's better
than the first season.
I feel like I've been
enjoying it a lot more
and they got like right
into it, it was nice.
No (beep)ing around.
- Yeah.
- It was good, yeah.
- I feel like the first season,
it did take a lot of time to get going.
I felt like it was just
like the first half
of Demon Slayer, Season One is, I mean,
it was just very standard
Shonen stuff, you know?
It was like, it was nice.
It was like comfort food, you know.
You knew what you were getting.
It was only until like
the (beep)ing spider rock
where I feel like it actually got...
- Yeah, kicked off.
- Really, really good.
- I feel like this season so
far I've I'm on episode seven.
Yeah, really impressed with it so far.
Not a single episode I thought was boring.
Pacing's really good,
animation is just God tier.
I must say like one aspect of Demon Slayer
that I've just like never
really understood is like,
I dunno, it's a good show, right,
but do you think it deserves
as much of like an insane hype
in Japan as it does?
- what do you mean in
Japan, it's worldwide.
- No, but like, I feel in Japan,
it's on another level.
- It's hard to explain
if you don't live here like how insane
the hype (indistinct).
- Like everyone knows Kimetsu
is (beep)ing popular everywhere, right?
Like everyone's watching the new season.
Everyone went to go see the new movie,
but like in Japan, when
I say so when something
is inescapable that I
feel Kimetsu in Japan
perfectly suits that word
because everywhere you look,
some product or some store or something
is doing something with Kimetsu.
- Even like five year olds to
like 80 year old grandfathers.
- Like my entire Japanese
side of the family has like
a favorite, like a top three
characters in Demon Slayer.
It's so weird like,
so I have like a four
year old cousin, right,
who obviously loves Demon Slayer, right,
because (beep)ing every kid
loves Demon Slayer right now.
So like for Christmas I was like
- [Connor] Breathing young.
- So for Christmas I was like,
I'm gonna get him something
Demon Slayer-related, right?
So I asked his mom, my
cousin, just being like,
what is his favorite a character, right?
And she just lists off like
two or three characters.
I was like, all right, cool, easy.
And then she was like, oh, by the way,
I like this character, your
uncle likes this character.
Your aunt likes this character.
And I'm like, what?
Imagine my 60-something
year old uncle being like,
yeah, I (beep)ing love Shinobu, dude.
She's just like my (beep)ing
favorite character.
I'm like that's so weird.
It's so weird how in Japan
literally every one of every
age generation is watching
Demon Slayer or has watched it.
- It's intense.
- Yeah.
- Do you think it's the
movie that's got it this big
'cause I didn't realize how big it was.
- No, I think...
- It was already big before.
- I think.
- Oh, yeah
How big it already is was the
reason why the movie's like
the (beep)ing like highest
grossing from all time.
- 'Cause like that one
year where it beat out
One Piece by manga sales
like tenfold or something.
- Yeah, it was, yeah.
- Oh, yeah.
- Before like, it was like
the years before that,
the top selling manga was like One Piece,
One Piece, One Piece, One
Piece, One Piece, One Piece.
Well like a long shot, and
then Demon Slayer came out,
and it was just like, yeah,
let me like 10 times
like your previous sales.
It hilarious when you saw the graph
'cause it was like all these
other's shown in jump stuff,
and then it's like One Piece.
It was like Demon Slayer.
- [Ashley] Because within 2019,
the rankings for like (speaking off mic)
rankings, like Demon
Slayer was like every week.
- Every, yeah it was every week.
- [Ashley] Jujutsu Kaisen
came out (speaking off mic)
It was like second and
first, and then like
it's a fight between Demon Slayer.
- I was going to say Jujutsu
Kaisen seems almost equally
as inescapable recently
'cause of the new movie.
- 'Cause of the new movie.
- Yeah, 'cause of the new
movie, but even before that,
like after he got released,
it just seemed like
it had such a big explosion,
and I'm not sure like,
I haven't been living in
Japan long enough to see
like how big or how
fast trends come and go.
But like it was way bigger than I thought
it was going to be.
- Yeah, I mean like,
in Japan trends come and go so quickly
because I feel once
something trends in Japan,
Japan just milks the
absolute (beep) out it like,
you know, throw it back,
if you can remember PPAP,
for instance back in the
(beep)ing day, right?
For you kids, that's
Pen-Pineapple-Apple-Pen.
When that was (beep)ing big,
like three or four years ago,
however longer it was.
- It was longer than that.
- I think it was longer than that, right?
Like that was (beep)ing
everywhere in Japan.
And it's crazy, like...
- So when you go to the
supermarket, they play it.
- Yeah, right, like it
still has staying power,
but like, I don't know.
I don't know what it is about
Demon Slayer specifically
when it comes to like a
trending anime in Japan.
Because every, I feel there's
all always that one series
that is trending
everywhere in Japan, right?
Like during the different
periods, it's like,
it's nothing new to Demon
Slayer, I feel, in Japan.
But I was like, what is it
about Demon Slayer specifically
that it's literally appealing
to every single generation?
- I don't know.
- I don't get it.
- It's weird.
- It's a good show.
- Doesn't really have like
the family- friendly appeal.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- Like I can't imagine a four year old
watching these demons, like
heads getting cut off, right?
Being like, ha ha ha, ha.
- It's not the same as like
Beauty and The Beast, you know?
- Yeah, right, it's not like a Disney IP
or, you know, like a Pixar IP
or anything like that, right,
where it can appeal to the family.
- Even comparing it to like
other anime or other Shonen.
It's it's good, it's good.
- It's a good show.
- Every time I make this
argument, people just think,
oh, you're just a Demon Slayer like hater.
I'm like, I'm not, I enjoy the show,
but I just don't understand
what about this show
specifically that is
literally inescapable.
- Don't even think it's
like my top three Shonen.
- Oh, it's definitely not in
my top three Shonen, it's not.
But the animation is just so good.
It makes it so easy to watch, right?
Oh, this is just amazing, it's insane.
- But the thing is it's not only
because of the anime though,
but because you know,
like the manga sales,
(talking over each other)
so it's something like
fundamental about Demon Slayer
that is somehow appealing to
everyone and I don't get it.
And yet, the run time of
the manga was so short.
- Someone needs to write
a (beep)ing dissertation on this man.
Like it is genuinely, really interesting
'cause I like, as good as Demon Slayer is,
I don't know how unique it is.
It's not...
- Right?
- It's not exceedingly unique
in any one aspect at all.
- And it's not like One
Piece that's been around
for, you know, a hundred volumes, right?
Like I think Demon Slayer
only has like 23, 24 volumes
or something, which for a Shonen
Jump manga is really short.
- Are there just this many
mouth breathers in the world?
Just like...
- Just, it's only mouth breathers
- Maybe they were just lying in wait.
- They come out from their basements.
- Like finally representation, all rise!
- The total concentration technique
is breathing through your nose.
- Take that ball gag out.
- My nose has been blocked
for like two weeks.
I've been a mouth breather for two weeks.
That's why I watched it.
- Really?
- Finally I can relate.
- I can relate to this anime.
- Hello gentlemen.
Today's episode is sponsored by Harry's.
2022 is the year to break
out with new routines.
This is the year where
you can gift yourself
or any fellow shavers a nice,
clean shave with Harry's.
Treat yourself or anyone
else the gift of looking
(beep) sharp this Valentine's Day.
New customers can redeem
a Harry's free trial set for just $3
by going to harrys.com/trashtaste.
Harry's delivers a close,
comfortable shave at a fair price.
Just $2 per blade, (beep) that is cheap.
Not only that, but Harry's blades
are designed to stay sharp for longer.
In a recent study, guys who
shaved four times a week
said that eighth shave was
just as smooth as their first.
New Harry's customers
can redeem a starter set.
You get a five-blade
razor, a weighted handle,
foaming shave gel with
aloe, and a travel cover
to protect all your blades
when you're on the go.
That's a $13 value for just $3.
Guys, it's literally free money.
There's truly never been a
better time to try Harry's.
Go to harrys.com/trashtaste
to try Harry's today.
Thank you to Harry's for
sponsoring this episode.
Back to the video.
What is even like the top
character in Demon Slayer
in terms of like popularity?
- In terms of popularity?
- Yeah.
- It's gotta be Tanjiro, right?
- [Garnt] Is it Tanjiro?
- It's...
- No, it's not Zenitsu.
- No, it's...
- No, it's not.
- Okay, this...
- I can see it, man.
- There is a lot of Zenitsu fans.
- Why?
- It's like, it depends because I think
the top five definitely is like Tanjiro,
Nezuko, Zenitsu, Agatsuma, and Shinobu
as like the top five.
But like hardcore fans, and
there's a lot of hardcore fans
in Japan, all love all of the Hashiras.
- Yeah, the Hashiras are pretty cute.
- That's you know, like,
I don't know if that's like
their way of being like,
yeah, I'm a true fan.
- Yeah, 'cause like
with some shows you immediately know
what the most popular
character's gonna be,
like Jujutsu Kaisen, it's
easily gonna be Gojo.
Yeah.
- That character was built
to be the most popular character.
- Exactly, right?
But like in, Demon Slayer,
you just don't know
who is gonna like, I can't
think who it's gonna be.
And if it's Zenitsu, then...
- I've lost hope with Zenitsu.
- I'm glad I'm not the only one
who can't (beep)ing stand Zenitsu.
- Saemi's so much cooler than Zenitsu.
I (beep)in' hate Zenitsu.
- I don't understand Zenitsu fans.
- I don't know, it's, I
mean, it's like I said,
it's,
it's a good show.
- She's relatable.
(talking and laughing over each other)
- I wish they wish they had some power
that could make them useful.
I'm joking, I'm joking.
- I know why the cast is popular.
'cause you can call every
character a cinnamon bun.
- That's...
- Why, why can you do that?
- I dunno.
- I hate you guys.
Don't say that (beep).
- I dunno, Kamchacha.
I'm trying to like
understand this myself, okay.
- It's such an interesting social study,
just because we've seen the anime market.
- (beep) your, your ENTP type,
whatever the (beep) it is.
Tell me your favorite Hashira.
That's how I know if you're a real dealer.
- (Beep) your star sign.
- Yeah, yeah.
You're a Zodiac cringe, bro.
Tell me your favorite Hashira and why.
- Update that match.com for a profile.
- Yeah, put that in the match.com profile.
- Before Demon Slayer,
what would you say was like
the biggest like kind of
cultural trend in terms of anime?
Has there been like an anime?
I'm sure there must have
been like other animes
that have...
- Yeah in terms of like.
- Call the Japanese public
as much as Demon Player is doing now?
- Slam Dunk back in the
day was definitely like...
- [Connor] That was Japan
though mainly, right?
- Yeah, in Japan, was like Slam Dunk
was so big it became
a cultural phenomenon.
- Are you asking in
Japan or like the world?
- I'm not asking in Japan.
I don't think in the world
there has been one yet.
- No, not really.
- No, not yet.
- One Punch Man was for a
little bit while it was out.
- I look at One Punch
Man and I'm just like...
- It was a big deal when it came out.
- It was a big deal, but I see
Attack on Titan, Season Four being
a bigger deal now.
- That's 'cause it's had
more time to brew.
- Yeah.
- It's had more time to like relish it.
- But even then comparing like
Attack on Titan, Season Four
to some like other mainstream
stuff, it's not there yet.
- It had hype, but it
didn't really create like
a cultural like shift or anything.
- Whereas like sometimes you see in Japan,
there is a show that comes
long that does create
a cultural shift, like
Slam Dunk back in the day.
- My Hero, maybe?
- I don't, My Hero?
- I don't know.
It's hard to say.
- [Connor] My Hero was really big here.
- It is really big here.
- It is really big.
I feel like...
- I feel like Demon Slayer was
just 1,000,000 times bigger.
- I feel like the My Hero hype train,
like we thought the My
Hero hype train was big
and then Demon Slayer came out.
Even though I think they're
like in terms of show quality,
they're around about the same...
- No, they're not.
- When we're all getting
into this, Connor.
We are not getting into this, Connor.
- I'm just saying, I'm just saying.
- Wait, which, which side are you on?
- I think Demon Slayer is much better
than My Hero.
- Okay, I agree with that.
- I agree.
- How are you comparing them, (beep) off.
- I, I, I, I...
Okay, in the grand scheme of things
I think that's they're
of like comparable level
of quality in terms of like
if someone wants to say,
- I'm looking forward
to the song right now.
(talking over each other)
- What I'm trying to say is that
if they prefer My Hero
Academia over Demon Slayer,
I'm not gonna lose my (beep)
unlike a lot of people
in the community, right.
- My Hero fell off, bro.
My Hero fell off, man.
(laughing and talking over each other)
Bro, My Hero took the
(talking over each other).
- Look, everyone's telling me
that My Hero's gonna come back
and see Season Six with the
My Villains Academia Arc,
which I've heard it's amazing.
It might be amazing, it's Shonen.
- That's what Black Clover fans
have been seen for years now.
And it literally hasn't
escaped out of the manga fans.
We all know this.
- I dunno what happened with
My Hero on Season Three.
It just became like a snore-fest.
- I didn't even get to that point.
- I couldn't believe I did.
I watched like Season Three and I was like
bored out my mind watching it.
I was like, this is so boring.
Just do something then,
have something happen.
- Be heroes.
- Leave school or something
for (beep)'s sake.
This is why Hunter Hunter was good
'cause they (beep)ing moved,
they actually did something.
They like got on with the (beep)ing storm.
- Until they didn't.
- Until he stopped writing it.
That's why the story stopped.
Not because he just kept going in, like...
It was like an I purgatory
at this (beep)in' school.
- Yeah, as an an anime only,
I think what drew me
(talking over each other).
Yeah, as what drew me out
of like what made me lose
a lot of hype between,
in My Hero was, you know,
the first few arcs would
concentrate on the school kids
doing their thing and I'm like, cool.
You're getting to see progression.
And then they started
introducing the wider world
of the heroes and like these bigger,
these like vast plots that like
pertain to the entire world.
And you're like, cool, this is
amazing, this is interesting.
Let's go back to high school afterwards.
And I'm just like, what?
How can you do this to me?
Like, let's go to, let's
go to a concert arc that I,
I don't give a (beep) about
where you just introduced like
the entire villain's world,
and I'm just like, and yeah.
- It feels torn 'cause you're like,
just leave the safety net, you know?
Just leave it.
- Yeah.
- Like you clearly have built
this world that's interesting.
I think everyone likes the world.
Just let them get outta school,
push them, come on, come on.
- Actually expand upon it.
- Get on with it.
like actually do it,
but I get it, it's safe.
You can milk it, you can
get 10 more years out of it.
Stay in the (beep)in'
school, never leave it.
- Well isn't isn't the manga ending soon?
- Yeah, the manga's ending soon.
Like this year, right?
- Right outta high school.
- They eventually get out of school?
(Ashley speaking off mic)
I'm never gonna finish it
'cause I've lost all interest
in the anime because I was like.
- I can't wait for these clips
to get (beep)ing clipped,
and put on Twitter out of context.
I can't wait for Shonen to Twitter
to get on our asses for these clips.
- (beep), they're My Hero
fans, what're they gonna do?
Ask their Mum for more Fortnite
or Roblox, like (beep) off.
- Mama, cancel my Trash Taste merch!
- Come on, it fell off, it fell off, man.
- It did, it did, L-Ratio.
- No one talks about it,
no one talks about My Hero.
- I think that's the biggest thing is
that I don't even think it's bad.
I just think it just...
- It got boring.
It just got boring.
- But yeah, I didn't hate it,
but like no one talks about it now.
I feel like there's no
point in watching it
'cause who am I gonna talk to
about it, no one watches it.
- Yeah, I mean, I, you
know, maybe the hype
might get reinvigorated in the new season.
Maybe Margaritas are
right, maybe, I don't know.
- If it is that good of
a season where everyone
gets back on the hype train, fine.
I'll be a normie, I'll jump
back on that hype train.
I'll get back into it, but like I need
a promise that something's
gonna (beep)in' happen.
- Yeah, but like, it's been like a season
and a half of just boring
stuff and it's been like
two movies of just boring stuff.
- Yeah, I watched the
movie in the cinema as well
and it was just like...
- I heard it was just a milk fest.
Yeah, well it was just nothing happened.
It was just like I felt
like I went in the loo.
- Well, that's what I hate
about Shonen movies in particular, right,
because like Demon Slayer
is like an exception
because that actually
adapted the manga, right?
But to me Shonen movies just feel like
very high budget filler episodes
where you watch the movie,
has pretty animation.
- To be in every One Piece movie.
- Yes, I mean every One Piece movie.
- That's true, that's why
I don't watch anime movies
'cause there's just big
fillers that make money.
- That is true.
- But I'm glad to see
I finally feel like Demon
Slayer finally figured out
how to make a (beep) ton
of money whilst also not
(beep)ing off TV watchers,
just release the movie,
make your billion dollars,
and then just be like,
hey guys, before the new season starts,
here are your list in 20 chunk
epi-, in 20 minute chunks.
You can just watch.
I thought that's great.
- The thing about the movie
is I remember watching it
and I remember thinking this
just feels like a TV season.
- Yeah.
- It literally had points
where I could feel where
it cuts off for an episode,
and then it continued.
- Get the money of the movie
but then keep the TV style.
- I mean, so many more series
are gonna start doing it
because of how (talking over each other).
I mean, I guaran(beep)ing-tee
Attack on Titan's gonna do it.
I have a feeling, I have this like...
- In what way?
- I have this
- Do you think?
- I have this gut feeling.
- I don't think they will.
- Do you think about the ending
of Attack on Titan is going to be a movie?
- Bold prediction, I think
it's gonna be a movie.
- No, they wouldn't.
- Because there's no way...
- It would be leaked.
- Because there's no way, there
is no (beep)ing way, right?
Like people in the industry
saw how good Demon Slayer
did financially for the industry and go,
we can do that again.
- I bet your tenfold hat on that, Joe.
I don't think it's gonna happen.
- Attack of Titan Final Movie Part One.
- I guarantee.
- Of three.
I am.
- I'm going to bold prediction.
I don't care if this
ends up being all like
pull the age things, bold prediction.
I think it's gonna be a movie.
- (Ashley speaking off mic)
- Yeah, but that was a pretty-cool.
- But that was a pretty cool, right?
- [Ashley] Yeah, but still
it actually pre-tells.
You have to know the characters.
- Does the Jujutsu Kaisen movie
follow any source material?
- [Ashley] They actually
release the prequel manga.
- There's a prequel manga that...
- [Ashley] So it kind of follows
the same formula as the...
- That's all I care about.
I just don't wanna, like
when I watch anime movies,
I just wanna know that I'm
not watching a filler episode.
(talking over each other)
- Like, look, don't get me wrong.
Don't get me wrong, I've
I've seen like almost all
the One Piece movies and they're fun,
but I'm not (beep)ing
on the edge of my seat
waiting for the next one.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know what you're going
into with a Shonen anime movie.
You know, what's gonna happen.
It's gonna be the very bog
standard three act structure
where you know exactly what's gonna happen
and how it's happen, maybe
there'll be a slight twist,
but you know, at the end of
the day, it all gets resolved
because the plot needs to
be resolved to move on.
It can't be exciting.
- It's just introduction,
conflict, resolution.
- And then we end up in
the exactly the same place
that we started.
- Because it has to.
- All the time.
- That's what sucks, and that's
why I have no interest in...
- And thus, they continued on their quest.
That's how it ends.
- Do you think that Chainsaw
Man getting released
this year is going to
reach the same heights
as Jujutsu Kaisen?
- I would hope.
- I would like it to.
- What I want to get...
- As a fan of the manga, I want this
to be talked about this more.
- Yeah.
- I have a feeling it definitely
has that potential now.
It's been a long time
since I've seen people
hype up this one IP this much.
Like I remember watching the trailer
and the trailer just like,
you felt like the trailer
just broke the (beep)ing
anime Twitter for the day.
Like it got like a million views in a day
on Twitter or something like that.
- Less than a day.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- It got like a million
likes, like the actual tweet.
- [Connor] That's crazy.
- Which is (beep)ing nuts
for an anime trailer.
- It did not fall off,
did not get ratioed.
No, it did not.
It ratioed every other anime trailer.
- [Connor] That's for sure.
- I just hope like the hype
doesn't collapse in on itself.
and everyone starts watching it
and people are just like, oh,
this wasn't as good as it...
- Yeah, that's what I'm really scared of.
I really hope Map will like
actually pull through with...
- I don't see why we have any
reason to doubt Map though.
- I don't doubt that.
- For Mapper or just like
collecting the infinity stones?
Yeah, they're killing it right now.
- Attack on Titan, did
you see Jujutsu Kaisen
(beep)in' Chainsaw Man?
- Yeah, that's true.
- I'm praying, I'm praying.
- Yeah, that was, that was the anime talk
of Trash Taste.
- we have a clear
just still dislike the
quarantine zone for anime.
No more anime (talking over each other).
No more anime for...
- Even enough outtakes for one anime.
- I feel like there's, that's really like,
from what I can see, I mean
the, the only memorable things
that people are gonna remember this season
are probably those shows.
- Yeah.
- And My Dress-Up Darling,
and that's pretty much going to be it.
- I think that's really good.
- The Manga's good.
- That's a good show.
I mean, I've only seen like two episodes.
It's a good show.
- This is what happens
when those kind of rom coms
or not slice of life, but kind of...
- Yeah, I dunno how to describe it.
That kind of genre of thing
comes out, it always comes out.
Everyone's like 10 outta 10, 10 outta 10.
Everyone, everyone, everyone
hypes it the (beep) up.
(talking over each other)
This is like the best anime,
and then no one talks about it.
Like right after it's gone,
it's like it's forgotten,
but like to this day, there's still like
Naruto, Naratu, Naratu, right?
Like you, it's never gone,
like, I don't know why.
- Can you really fault me
for not watching anime?
- I don't know, I guess
that's 'cause maybe
the characters you can't speculate
as much about or whatever, but.
- Well, like Naruto is like,
was a long running series that were...
- A lot more, more grandiose and such.
- Garnt's girlfriend,
that's grandiose, right?
It's grandiose. (everyone
laughing hysterically)
- That's grandiose.
- (audio cutting out)
you're rooting for, right?
Big moments, big (beeps).
- Big plot twists.
Am I right, Connor?
- NGR?
It's got everything you could
speculate about on YouTube.
- I can't wait for Season
Two of Rent-A-Girlfriend.
- See, I want those
videos where it's like,
you know how like in those
Naruto YouTube videos,
like what if thingy went against thingy,
and then they speculate it and it's like,
what if the main protagonist
from Rent-A-Girlfriend went on Tinder?
Let's speculate how well he would do.
Personally, I think he would
get a success rate of 95%.
He'd be slaying, you know?
- But that's just the theory.
- That's just what I'm saying.
Lemme know down below, everyone's
like fighting and I dunno.
- How dare he make that speculation?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Honestly, I mean, I believe
when Rent-A-Girlfriend
Season Two comes out that's
going to be worth watching
because that arc is
legitimately going to be good.
- Is it gonna cover that chapter though?
- No, I shouldn't have
brought up Rent-A-Girlfriend.
I should have, you know,
you were gonna bring it up
so many times.
- It's the most excited
he's been entire episode.
- You're so happy though.
- I just not, I, I, I can't hear
Rent-A-Girlfriend now
without just laughing.
- There's some real clown (beep)
- If, if you know, you
know, like it's like, it's.
I feel sorry for anime early watchers
because they're gonna watch season two
and they're gonna think it's really good
'cause it, it was a really
good, it was a really good arc,
and they're not gonna know
what they have coming.
- They'll never know what hit 'em.
- They'll never know
what what's waiting for
them on the other side.
- Oh, man.
- I guess we're done talking about anime.
- Yeah, stop talking about anime now.
We, everyone leaves.
- This is it.
This this is your anime talk for the year.
- Finally played 13 Sentinels
after Garnt's recommendation last week?
- Yep, I beat it in three days.
- Yeah, so obviously you
guys watched last week
where I recommended 13
Sentinels to these guys.
So I thought, you know, I
didn't know if they would take
my recommendation or not.
- Garnt's in the well of recommendations.
- Yeah, I was just like, you know,
I'm just gonna continue playing it.
I'm like playing it at a comfortable pace.
And then three days after recording,
Joey texts me and goes,
I finished 13 Sentinels.
What the (beep), Joey!
- I literally went home
that recording night,
downloaded it, started playing. I play.
I was like, I'll give it a
couple of hours, all right?
Just like, like as Garnt said
I'll give it a couple of
hours just to warm up.
See if I even get into the groove.
I got into the groove all right
because the three days after that,
it was just me waking up
having like six coffees
just so I could (beep)ing
stay focused in this game.
Playing it for like 10
to 12 hours straight
and going to bed.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
- It is like,
now that I have someone
to talk to it about,
I can, without spoiling it.
- We can't talk about it.
- We can't talk about it because like
I get like now someone finally understands
that I actually think 13 Sentinels
might be the most insane
plot I've ever seen
in a video game and I
haven't even finished it yet.
Yeah, it is by far one
of the craziest like
video game stories or
just stories in general,
I've like sat through.
- Yeah.
It's like, so Garnt last
week made the comparison
of it's like Bokurano mixed
with Steins Gate, all right?
As someone who's finished the game,
I can say he's right on that.
But only on like a surface level
because it's like, it
has elements of Bokurano,
like with the robots, and it
has elements of Steins Gate,
which is the time traveling aspect.
But then you combine that with like
Ghost in the Shell and The Matrix.
- Oh, God.
- And just imagine all four of
those mashed into one story.
- How is that cohesive?
- Somehow, I don't know how.
- I don't know how
they did it, but it is cohesive.
- Out of 10, out of 10?
- Like strong nine.
- Wow.
- I haven't finished it
yet, but like playing
through it now, you get to about the third
of the way point, right,
and you think like,
'cause I'm gonna say there are twists.
- Obviously.
- You don't say.
- There are...
- Don't spoil anything.
- There are twists in this
story and I remember getting
about a third of the way through.
I'm just like, I know the
twist that's gonna happen.
I know that's gonna happen,
and then sure enough,
what I predicted happened,
and then that was just like
the twist that leaded into another twist
that leaded into a (beep)ing bigger twist.
- There were moments as I was playing,
especially the second
half, where you think like,
you're like, all right, this
same story has been told
from 13 different perspectives, right?
So you're like, so you follow everything.
You're like, okay, I think
I know what's going on.
And I think I can predict
what's about to happen.
But there were moments where
a character would say one line
and I literally have to
put my controller down
just to be like, I don't
believe you just said that
because now what I thought
I knew about this game
is completely out of the window.
- Okay, enough.
- But it's still,
but it doesn't come
outta left field either.
I genuinely want to know...
- What the writing process.
- What the writing processes is.
It's so insane how many
times you get (beep)in'
actual physical whiplash
for like new plot elements
that get added that seems that make,
that it's like bat (beep) crazy
if you explain it outta context.
But like in context, it
makes the most perfect sense.
It makes perfect sense.
It makes like the (beep)ing
Fate Law look like Disney.
You know, Kingdom.
- I think I said to Garnt,
I texted Garnt saying it
makes the Kingdom Hearts Law
look like Sesame street.
- Like, Kingdom Heart
fans are going finally.
I can hear a story I can
follow along with you know,
like it's like, I can't put into words
how actual insane in the story is,
but it's (beep)ing incredible.
It works, I dunno how it
works, but it just does.
- Like, and, and we were saying like,
I don't know how more people
haven't heard about this.
Even in like the JRPG community
Cause even like the JRPG community
is a very tight-knit community where as
if something's good, you
normally hear about it from about
from like five different
people in the JRPG community.
- I think the problem is that
because when I tweeted out about it,
I thought I was gonna maybe get like
three people being like, woo,
you know, about it, right.
because again, you don't
hear about it, but like,
I think it just like
opened the hatch and like
all the 13 Sentinel fans came
up being like, yo, let's go
because I got so much (beep)ing support
for being like, oh, he's finally
(beep)in' played the game.
We've all been trying to get
him to play kind of deal.
And it's like, I looked
in, cause I was curious,
I looked into it being
like, why have I not heard
of this game until Garnt told me about it.
And it's because Atlas
put literally zero money
into the marketing, so they
kind of just released it
and was like, if you
find it, here's a gem,
but if you don't find it, then
you'll never know it existed.
And I don't...
- Don't do any marketing?
- It's because it's literally
impossible to explain
the story without spoiling it.
Actually, scratch that.
It's literally impossible to
explain the story, period.
Even if I did spoil
it, I can't explain it.
- I was like considering
doing a Twitch stream
for this play-through 'cause I was like
more people need to like
experience the story.
But then I was like
thinking about what would
the experience be like for a viewer?
And like, if you switch
off for like five minutes,
you go, you go make a
cup of tea or something.
You're completely (beep)ing lost again
'cause then you've missed
a piece of information
that's important to someone
else's plot somewhere.
- How long is the game total?
- I'd say around 30 hours?
- I think I put in like 32, 33 hours.
- I'd say that's...
- Which is short for a JRPG.
- I was gonna say that's probably
not a bad length to stream a game.
I'd say any game that
takes like over, like,
If you're doing a full-time shift, right,
let's say eight hours, if
it takes more than a week,
it's probably too long for Twitch.
- I mean I tried to stream
The Opposite of Seven,
and that's a really, really long game.
And a lot of people fell off like
maybe like after like
stream six, stream seven.
Yeah, which is understandable.
- People do like those
types of games to watch,
especially people who have played it.
They (beep)ing love those streams
'cause they're like, I wanna see
- The reaction.
- Someone else, yeah.
- Reaction to the bits
that I thought was insane.
- Yeah.
- So that that's cool,
but also, I don't know, it's easier.
It's normally easier to stream
those kind of games as well
'cause you're like, you're
so invested that, like,
it doesn't feel like you're alive almost.
I'm just so into this.
- I think as well, the problem I,
'cause I thought about it too.
I was like maybe I should stream it.
I don't know, but I
thought about it and like,
I'm glad I didn't because
the reason why I played it
back-to-back three days in
a row is because I thought
to myself, if I don't play
this game for more than a day,
I'm going to forget everything.
- Have you forgotten everything now?
- A lot of it, yeah, but
like, I remember how it ends,
but like it's the build up
to how to get to that end
which is what makes it so interesting.
- It's like you have the
beginning and the end,
and the beginning's just like this,
and then some way it just goes whoosh!
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then you're just
like, I, we're here.
- We made it here somehow.
- I don't know how we got
here, but we got here.
- We got here.
- And it was a bat-(beep), insane journey,
but it's like one of the, most, it is...
- It is literally the
sourced intro to the game.
It's just like you, like, in this game,
you follow as this protagonist, or do you?
- I have tempted to play
'cause you guys have hyped it up so much,
but I'm like, I would have to stream it.
I couldn't justify
playing a game that much
and not, not monetizing it
That's crazy.
- God forbid.
- I wanna, okay, the thing is
I wanna see you try and do it
just to see, no, no, no, no, just to see
if your audience can even keep up.
- I don't even know if I can keep up, bro.
Is there a skip option for the cut scenes?
- It's all cut scenes.
- Oh, (beep).
- That's gonna be hard to not.
- I mean, you're basically...
- Do they give you options to skip?
- No, okay, let's get that...
- There is a fast forward option
for dialogue you've already experienced,
but like...
- Because you experience
the same scenes most of the time.
- I say this with like zero
irony, you need the dialogue.
- You need the dialogue.
- I know you do, that's
the thing is it's hard
'cause if I'm like,
the skip buttons there.
- Let's just say it's not a
game I can see you playing.
- No.
Yeah, yeah.
- That's probably why I
think it would be funny
to play it as well cause I'm just like...
While you spent three days playing that,
I spent three days, four
days playing Jump King.
- Four days playing Jump King?
Yeah, how was that experience?
- Hell.
- Yeah.
- Awful.
- It looked like it,
while I was enjoying
myself in my own space,
you were being ridiculed by
tens of thousands of people.
- Yeah, I know, I, yeah, it was tough.
It's tough, it's really
like soul destroying.
- Yeah.
- I don't know.
It's a really good game though.
- I wanna play it.
- I don't know how to describe it.
It's like when Calli was on
and talking to us about it,
I don't think you can appreciate this game
and how difficult it is until you play it.
- Yeah, I certainly didn't
because looking at it,
it looks so simple that it...
- Yeah, it looks easy.
- It looks so simple.
- How hard can it be to
- Just jump in it.
- Jump, just jump
- Like how hard can it
be to judge the jump,
but then you're like, oh, okay.
Well the only instinct that gives you,
like, you cannot see any
indication of how long
this jump is gonna be other
than your muscle memory.
How long you hold the
space bar or controller
and how long are you gonna jump?
And it is soul crushing
because there are some jumps
where it's like, it is like...
- Pixel perfect?
- Yeah, there's like a 1/10th
of a millisecond window
where you have to get it
precise, and if you (beep) it up,
you have to go back and
do 50+ perfect jumps
to get to the opportunity
to (beep) that one up again,
which you'll probably (beep) up again.
So it's really soul destroying and yeah.
At the first game, I beat it,
I did it in one eight-hour
stream which was long,
but it was fun 'cause, you know, I left
text-to-speech things on so
people were just insulting me.
They were like Connor, you can't stream.
You can't keep streaming this.
You'll get a DM save for streaming
White Men Can't Jump and stuff like that.
And they were like, Connor,
just turn your monitor upside down.
You'll be making good
progress, and stuff like that.
Just insulting me, and it was really fun.
I think it made for a really good stream.
And then I decided, 'cause Calli said
that she think I could do the DLC,
and I regret doing the DLC.
The DLC was so much.
- Yeah, yeah.
I remember you finishing
the original Jump King
in like one day and
everyone's like celebrating.
I was like good for you, 'cause I remember
tuning in the morning
and tuning in the night
and I'm just like Connor's
still (beep)ing on this.
He was all on this bull(beep).
And he was like, finally, you've done it.
And then when I saw Calli told
you to do the DLC as well,
I was like, oh, so it's
just a little extra
that would take like half the time.
- Extra bonus.
- An extra bonus stage
that will take half the time.
And I remember tuning in one day
you were doing it tuning in the next day,
you were still doing it.
- I was like, (beep) this
guy really likes this game.
- Cruel man, the DLC is so much
harder than their base game.
So I think, I dunno how
many people have beaten
the base game, but I know
that only 2% of the people
who have it on stream beat the second DLC.
And there's a third DLC,
which is even harder,
which I'm too afraid to attempt.
- Didn't Ludwig beat like all
three of them in like an hour.
- Yeah, Ludwig's insane, yeah.
I think Ludwig's first run of
it though did take 40 hours
of the last DLC, so just like.
- Built different.
- He's crazy though, he is insane.
I'm like you can't appreciate these games
and how good Ludwig is at them
until you do them yourself.
And you're like, this is insanity.
Like this is insane.
Like the sheer amount of
muscle memory required
for this game is just absurd.
- It's like a frob software game, right?
(talking over each other)
Muscle memory.
- If you die a dog soldier,
you go back to the swamp point,
which could be far, but
in this game it's like,
you can lose like two hours of progress.
- There's like no
checkpoint anywhere, right?
- No, so the base game, there's
points where you can get
to where you're kind of safe.
You can't fall too far,
but the second DLC, there's points
where like you can fall massively.
And there's never any safe points.
And in the third one
again, there's another,
even harsher jump, and it's just brutal.
I recommend trying it.
I don't know why.
It's kind of
- Yeah, I wanna try it.
- Yeah, I wanna try it as well.
- Although, you know, there's rage games.
There's like not, not like
getting over it, but like,
you know, there's like Cat
Mario games back in the day.
It's like those flash games
where they just like troll.
It was just (beep)ing with you.
This game was, it feels
like you never blame
the game when you fail.
Like it's always you.
You were the one who didn't do it right.
You never feel like you
were unfairly played.
There are some sneaky things
they do here and there.
But it's a very rewarding experience.
However, I do not wanna do
it again for a long time.
I had horrible anxiety on the last day
because I was getting to the end.
I just wanted it to be (fuck)ing over with
'cause I was so close and if I fell,
I would go all the way back down.
And it's just horrible.
I think my heart rate was like resting
at like 110 or something
'cause it was just,
it was nerve wracking 'cause you know
if you (beep) up this one jump
you gotta redo it for three hours.
So that's one point during
the DLC on the 2nd day
where halfway through the stream,
I'd gotten into the final part.
And I was like, oh my God.
Somehow, like I was stuck
on this one stage for hours,
and then I just started going through
all the stages perfectly, and
I was on the very last stage
and I was like, oh my
God, I'm gonna do it.
Like my heart is like 120.
I'm like (beep)ing holding the space bar
and then I'd do one big (beep) up,
and I lose like half
the progress I'd made.
And I couldn't, and
the rest of the stream,
I couldn't get back to where I was.
I was just so miserable,
I went to bed just so sad.
I was like, this is horrible.
I just couldn't do it, I couldn't do that.
I'm a fake gamer. I couldn't do it.
- Why would you do that to yourself?
- Because that, that...
- Content, isn't it?
- It was the content,
fantastic Twitch content.
People love watching a man
go insane and be miserable.
- Of course they do.
- You know.
I dunno why anyone would ever
play those games just for fun.
- On all hours straight.
- I only did it...
- Yeah, I was gonna ask
would you ever consider
playing a game like this if you didn't
stream it?
- Absolutely not.
No you couldn't, but why would you do,
because there's absolutely
no reason to do it, right?
If I do it on Twitch, it's like, okay,
well, it's great content.
People, it's really easy
to understand, you know.
You played 13 Sentinels.
It's like hey, so here's
the 15 characters.
You need to know all the in
depth law about, by the way,
miss 10 seconds of dialogue,
that changes everything.
- Jump King, it's like
my Mum can understand it.
If you fall, that's bad.
- [Garnt] You're a king who jumps.
- You literally go up and if you fall,
you can sometimes fall really far.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And that's bad, you know.
It's super easy to get people invested in.
And yeah, it's just fun
watching someone go insane.
I think, I don't know, I
would never do it off stream.
- Yeah, of course.
- Ever, why would you?
I don't understand why
people have done it.
What compels you to keep going?
What compelled me to keep going.
- Self-satisfaction, right?
- Yeah, right.
What compelled me to keep going
is that I don't want people
to call me a little bitch for quitting.
So I was like, I've gotta keep going.
Everyone's gonna call me a little bitch.
- Basically.
- I also am very stubborn, so.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
- Callie's still going.
- Callie is still going right now.
Is that the 3rd DLC?
- Yeah. Yeah.
But I mean, by the time this has gone on
I'm sure Callie's beating it, right?
I'm sure.
- Let's hope so.
- Hope you, hope you...
- Callie's insane, Callie
also is like insane on it.
Callie beat the base game in
like an eight-minute speed run.
Very insane.
- Holy (beep).
- Yeah, really good stuff, real insane.
Again, I've much more appreciation
for anyone who beat that game now.
- Would you ever consider speed running?
- Yeah, I was about to
ask, would you ever want..
- Yeah, I would the base game.
Base game is like easy mode now.
Like that's, there's only a few jumps
that scare me in the base one.
The rest of it's like super easy
'cause there's like
there's margin of error
'cause like, if the platform's wider,
you can obviously move
a lot, but sometimes
they do like just like a little pole.
and you have literally like,
you have to get the arc perfect.
- Right.
And sometimes there's ice on the platform
so you can fall off or
they're rounded, so you can...
- It just sounds like those
like really punishing,
like NES and like Super Nintendo games.
I feel that's like kind
of becoming a trend again
especially in the gaming
like e-world, I feel.
- I feel like, but
sometimes those NES games
were just bull(beep).
- Oh, yeah.
They were like unfair.
I feel like this was an experience
that is very challenging,
but also very rewarding weirdly.
Like I've never felt more
accomplished about a video game.
- Yeah, I felt that when
I streamed Hollow Night
a while back, like that game
is like (beep)ing unforgiving
in some ways, and to this
day I haven't beaten it
just 'cause this is one ball stone
where I'm just like, this is bull(beep).
- Right, right.
Those are the types of games that when
we finally overcome it...
- But when you beat it,
when you finally beat it,
(beep), yeah, let's go.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
I don't know, I feel like I learned
a lot about myself in those 30 hours.
I learned an awful lot about
me and who I am by just.
- You kind of have to, right.
You play a game like that for that long,
which I don't know how
the (beep) you do it.
Respect to you for being a true gamer.
I can't even play game.
I can't even play a game that
has like more than five inputs
for like more than three hours, you know.
(Beep)ing just pressing one space bar
and just jumping for like 10 hours.
I can't (beep)ing do that.
I was sweating playing 13 Sentinels
and you literally just
press soak for awhile.
- I'm sure I'm getting,
I'm pretty sure I'm getting
repetitive strain injury,
repetitive, what is it called?
- Ah, RSI?
- RSI.
- I was pretty sure
I was getting that after a
while 'cause I was like...
It's mind-numbing.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- It's good though.
I really do recommend trying it.
- I definitely wanna stream it.
- Just to, you should, I
really wanna see you stream it.
- We should race.
- Huh?
- Yeah, you guys should
do a stream together.
- We should race it.
- I'll commentate.
- That's stressful.
- No, it's fun, 'cause if
you, no one expects you
- I don't wanna do it on my own.
- Listen, the first time.
- So you want me to suffer more, Joey.
- I don't want to be alone by myself
with Chad just (beep)ing
doing this, right?
- I want someone to be there with me.
- People would love that.
People would love that,
you gotta do this now.
This is a brilliant idea.
- Yeah, come on, let's do it.
- If you go in...
Yes, Garnt, do it.
- I'm dragging you in.
- It's easy.
Just press the space bar.
- I'll (beep)in' do it, I
just love the way Joey's like,
yeah, I'll do it, right, Garnt?
You're with me, right?
- Don't say you're gonna beat it.
Just say you're gonna just gonna play it.
Let's see what happens.
- If I play, I'm gonna beat it.
That's the thing, right, if I start...
If I start, I'm saying it.
If I start, then that's my commitment.
- Well now we can't
(beep)ing do it with you
'cause I have to finish it now.
[Connor] - You don't have
to, you don't have to.
No, you don't, you
don't, you don't have to.
You don't have to, you can do it.
- You know what, Mama
didn't raise no quitter.
- Mama didn't raise a bitch.
- It's in 4K, Garnt.
- She raised someone who
was so afraid of failure
that if you don't start
something, you don't need to quit.
- You're gonna play it,
you're gonna play it,
both, you should do it.
- Oh my God.
- But no, like yeah.
I mean, it looks fun, I guess.
- Big air quotations in fun.
- Like you completing it looked fun.
I didn't like see...
- It didn't look fun,
it looked satisfying.
- It's very satisfying.
- It's very satisfying. Yeah.
It's got a good soundtrack too.
- Yeah.
- Meanwhile, like Joey's
doing his best to try
and like convince me to not pick up
Final Fantasy online because...
- Shut up! (background noise
drowns out other sounds)
I'm doing this man a favor right now.
- I'm saving a life.
- [Ashley] Whoo!
- It was like a (talking over
each other) game, apparently?
- So last week, I off, like me and Sydney
off-handedly mentioned that
we maybe were interested
in getting into Final Fantasy Online,
and Joey like, Joey perked
up, like we just mentioned
that we wanted to try crack
or heroin or something.
It's like, Garnt, what did you just say?
- I think I'd be more understanding
if you said you wanted
to try heroin, you know.
I think doing heroin is
less life-threatening.
- Is it that addictive?
- I guess.
I've had friends who have
started it since day one
because they're big, Final Fantasy fans,
and myself, I was like,
okay, I'll give it a go.
But then I remember, but
then like 'Nam flashbacks
came back to me of like
times where I used to be
like heavily addicted to MMOs, right?
Where like, I would literally, what,
basically think of my three
day streak with 13 Sentinels,
but over the course of like three years.
- Yeah.
- Right, right?
That was my experience with MMOs, right?
- Right, that's why I don't touch them.
- And so I tried it.
I did the trial for Final
Fantasy 14 'cause you could do
like a trial period without
actually purchasing the game.
And I did that, really fun,
but I was, I stopped myself.
I was like, no, I
cannot, I cannot do this.
- You've got some willpower.
- I, dude, I must, I
unlocked 100% of my brain
to be like, Joey, you
are not doing this now,
not during the busiest year of your life.
You are not gonna upload
for a year straight
if you start this right now.
- Yeah, 'cause I didn't notice, like
I didn't know what you were
doing in the, like the past
the days that you were
playing 13 Sentinels,
but I did notice, normally Joey uploads,
like every other day on his Joey channel.
Suddenly he stopped uploading.
Dude, I didn't even tweet for three days.
I was like, I was literally
shut out from the world.
- Was it the gamer thing where you wake up
and immediately start
playing until you fall asleep
for three days?
- Yes.
- Oh, I love those, love those.
- That was me for three
days with 13 Sentinels.
But like, but like 14, Final Fantasy 14,
I was like, I'm going to be that way.
I just know it because I
love Final Fantasy games.
I love MMOs, and like every
around me is playing it as well,
right, so I'm like
there's no better feeling
than playing an MMO with
a bunch of mates, right?
That's true obviously.
So I was like, no, I have to stop myself.
I wanna be a responsible adult
that actually does what he needs
to do and what's important.
- You need to be a functioning adult.
- I need to be a functioning
member of society
and I'm not going to do this.
And then, you know, and (beep)ing
all my friends are like,
so when are you gonna start 14 Joey?
I'm like, stop it.
- It's like the forbidden thing.
I just don't go near them.
- Yeah.
- I just, I know that they're
bad for everything in life.
- Exactly.
I'm sure I'll have fun.
- You were you like into WoW
and MMOs back in the day?
(talking over each other)
- You know, looking back, I
just think this is insane.
I would just sit there clicking
on trees for eight hours.
- Right?
- And I'm like, what is this?
- Yeah.
- I can't, why did I do that?
I'm so emotionally invested.
- Yeah, like, don't get me wrong.
If I was a teenager like
now and 14 came out,
I'd be on that (beep)
(beep)ing every day, right
but because I have less
responsibilities than I do now.
- Yeah, 'cause when we
did the Room Scape stream,
like I remember I had a lot of fun
and then it dawns on me
that whatever we were doing
was like twice the speed or
like how much faster was it?
- Was like 20, 20 or 10 times.
- Yeah.
- It's it was like more
than 10 times the speed.
- It was 20 times speed?
- It was like, yeah, it
was like 20, 10 or 20 XP.
- Yeah.
- But it took us the whole day
just to get to one single boss battle.
- Welcome to Room Scape.
- How long would that take
if we didn't have the
XP ball to play with?
- Probably...
- A lot, I don't...
- Like a couple weeks.
- Yeah, like in Room Scape
as well, I think like the last few levels
are like the equivalent to
the entire like levels before.
- Yeah.
- So like getting to like 95,
and doing like to 99 is like
the same as getting to 95.
- Literally, man discovers how much
of a grind Room Scape is.
- People say One Piece
fans have commitment.
Like what?
- Well, the thing was, I think the thing
that made Room Scape so kind of addictive
is that you could kind of just
like, kind of hands off it,
but kind of not, like you could
just kind of it's other monitor (beep).
You can just click.
I knew people who would do that.
They would have their normal life,
but always have, have Room
Scape on the other monitor
and they would be like...
- Kinda sounds like a catch game.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm just gonna say it.
- Pretty much, pretty much.
- But they're never gonna
cut you off, they never
had sanity or anything.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh, what's the other one?
- It's like playing Achmeds
with unlimited sanity.
This just never ends.
- Yeah, yeah, it literally was like,
it's just, it never stopped you.
I think that's what made it so good.
'cause they never tried to stop you.
- [Joey] Yeah, right.
I feel like people
probably put more money in,
cause it wouldn't stop
you, but they never had,
they just had a membership.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Those were the good old days.
- Good old days (talking over each other).
- So yeah, I'm doing everything
in my power right now
to stop Garnt and Sydney from
getting Final Fantasy 14.
'cause...
- You shouldn't.
You shouldn't.
- I mean, we were just
like mildly curious, right?
We were just like, we were just like,
maybe we maybe we'll look into this.
And then...
- That's how every
drug addiction starts.
- We were just like...
- Mild curiosity.
- We were just like mildly curious.
And then we saw that it
had gotten so popular
that they literally
removed it from the store
'cause I remember we just
tried to like download.
- So that made you want to have to play.
- Yes.
- Whoa.
- Classic, classic Tinder lover.
If it's hard to get, then
he wants it even more.
- So like Sydney like mentions
that she's gonna try and download it.
And I'm like, I'm like downstairs playing
my 13 Sentinels or
whatever, and she's like,
"Garnt, I don't know what's wrong,
"but I don't, I can't download it."
And I'm just (beep) it, "Sydney,
come on, come on Sydney."
- [Connor] Come on, woman!
- "Have you never downloaded
a game before Sydney?
"Come on," and I so I
go up and I'm just like,
"Sydney, you press the download button."
And I'm like trying to
scroll down to find out
where the (beep) this download button is.
I'm like, is this the download button?
No, just goes into another pop-up.
And I'm like trying to
like navigate this site.
I like try to go to the steam page.
There's gotta be a download button.
So I'm like, I'm like so confused.
And then I realized that
they had to like take it off the store.
- Because their servers
literally aren't big enough.
- Yeah, because the servers literally
are too small to handle the player influx
that came in with the new expansion.
- Mind you, this is Square Enix,
literally one of the
biggest (beep)ing games.
- What's so good about this expansion
that like...
- I don't know, but now...
- It's the story.
- I wanna know.
- I've I've heard it's the story, right?
- And when we couldn't
download it, I'm just like,
okay, is there any other
way to download it?
So I start researching to
see if there's any other way
to download it 'cause now I
really wanna (beep)in' play it.
- What, are you like hacking
into the streaming server?
- Yeah.
- Garnt's like where is it?
- I'm just like, there must be a way.
No, they couldn't have just,
they couldn't have just
taken the file away.
Surely there's a way to download the file,
but like it's yeah, yeah.
You, you literally can't download it.
You can't buy it, You can't any, like
it's the only instance I've
seen in the gaming community
where I've tried to give a money company
and they've refused to accept my money.
- A money company.
- Sorry, a company money.
I've tried to give a company my money
and they refuse to accept it.
- Just throw it in the air.
Just let the service be broken
and still take the money.
I'll fix it, we'll fix.
- Yeah, well, we'll definitely fix it.
- Yeah, so I've heard
sales are coming back
on the 25th of February, so...
- Stop.
- No, of January, sorry.
So that's that's coming up, so...
- The reason why 16's been
delayed for like two years
is because (speaking off mic).
- I remember when that
game initially released
the Final Fantasy Online,
but it was terrible.
- Yeah.
- Right.
It was so bad that they
removed it and they built it.
They built it up from scratch.
- Yeah.
- Again.
And then the rerelease
just (beep)ing exploded.
- Yeah, well I even
remember when it re-released
that wasn't that big, was
it, I don't think it was.
- It was big, but nowhere
near as it is now.
- Now it's there, I can't escape it.
- Yeah, it's been a game where I remember
like one or two people talking about it.
It wasn't like a massive explosion,
but like slowly over time,
I just keep hearing it
more and more and more.
It's it's really, it really
just (beep)ing exploded
with this new Endwalker expansion.
That's the name, right, Endwalker?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You know, you know,
I've been to a lot of like
themed cafes in Japan, but
the most I've ever been
to one cafe is the (beep)ing
Final Fantasy 14 Cafe
just 'cause all my friends like,
"You wanna go to the Final
Fantasy 14 Cafe again?"
I'm like, I don't even
know this game, dude.
Why are you dragging me into this?
(Ashley speaking off mic)
Shut up!
- Yeah, I don't know, I mean,
I'm sure it's a good game.
I'm just never gonna do it
because I don't wanna get addicted.
- It's a good game.
I just, you know, have
responsibilities now.
- I mean I'm sure it's a good game
and I've just been looking
for a new game to get into
because it's like...
- Minesweeper.
- Hmm?
- You know like there's
there's games like Jump King
where you know, I'll play it for content,
but I also want a game
where I can just play.
- You want a comfort game.
- Yeah, I want a comfort
game 'cause once 13 Sentinels
gets finished, I just dunno
what I'm gonna do with my life.
- We grow when we leave our comfort zone.
We accomplish things when
we leave our comfort.
You think they climbed Everest
in their comfort zone, Garnt?
- You know what I, I would
learn like right now,
you know, we fill that void with more work
and I would like to know what happens
if we just do something
fun instead of filling
that void with a more work.
- Well, certainly not Final Fantasy
'cause I'll never (beep)ing see you.
Trash Taste will be on hiatus.
- Yeah, exactly.
Like what the (beep)
happened to Trash Taste.
Garnt and Joey are playing
Final Fantasy Online.
- Remember when they
promised like three specials
this year or what's happening with that?
- I don't want you to be the Togashi
of Trash Taste, all right?
I want you to be present
and here, no hiatuses.
- Garnt will be like,
he'll break down, like,
he'll call in to like Zoom and (beep).
He'll be like, I'm doing a raid right now,
but I can Trash Taste.
- If we can talk about Final Fantasy 14.
- Oh my God.
(Ashley speaking off mic)
- How long were you?
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- This, yeah (beep)ing Navi,
this mother(beep)er like...
you know how he tried to
convince me to play 14?
He was like, they have
Mahjongg in Final Fantasy 14.
I'm like, what do you think,
I'm some kind of like,
just because there's Mahjongg.
- Like no one's playing you for Poker.
- Just cause there Marjong in a game
doesn't mean I'm gonna be
like that, just give it to me.
- Like what do you think I am?
- But like, like you're the dog.
This is like the cheese
and the pill, swallow.
Swallow, swallow the pill, Joey.
You like, it's in a layer of cheese.
- It's like Pavlov's dog from Mahjongg.
- It's like Mahjongg, Mahjongg, Mahjongg,
yes, I'm playing it.
It's like.
- So rude.
I'm looking forward to
is the new Kirby game.
- That looked pretty cool.
- Yeah, it's like Kirby 64, but on Switch.
So it looks (beep)ing amazing.
- Yeah, I'm I'm looking forward
to the new Horizon: Zero
Dawn 'cause the first one
is one of my favorite games of all time.
Like I've been waiting, biding my time,
all this, like for like the past two years
to like not buy a PS5
or to like to buy a PS5
when the price has finally gone down,
And you're not just buying
it from like scrapers
or whatever, right.
And it's like, there's now a
game I want to play on PS5,
but it's still not (beep)ing available.
So (beep) my life.
- Bottom scrapers, sorry, Garnt.
- Scalpers.
- I was like, is that the name?
Is that the name?
- Scalpers.
- Bottom scrapers.
- They are bottom scrapers.
- Oh, that's what I was thinking.
They're like (beep)ing, they
are bottom scrapers, right?
- Yeah.
So it looks like I'm going
to have to try and buy
a PS5 sometime just to
play this game and...
- Get it.
- Yeah.
Is there enough games on the PS5 like
that are exclusive at the current moment?
- No.
- Right?
'Cause for my rule of
thumb with new consoles
is I need at least like maybe three games
where I'm like, I really wanna play this.
That'll get me to finally buy it.
Like that's what I did with the Switch.
That's what I did with the PS4.
Like if it's just like one or two games,
then I'm like, what am I gonna
do after I finish that game?
I'm only getting a PS5
just because that's how much I like...
Oh, that's not much.
I like the original
Horizon series Zero Dawn.
I need to play this game at launch
- I only bought a PS4 to
play Persona Five, so yeah.
- What are the really big games
that are available on the PS5?
I don't know, Demon's Souls?
(talking over each other)
- The Spider-Man game.
- Oh, the Spider-Man game.
- Right, right.
(Ashley speaking off mic)
- FF7 Remake.
- Is it actually?
- [Ashley] If I'm mistaken,
that's why I got the PS.
- It doesn't feel like a
true PS5 or like a Next-Gen,
and if it's on like the Gen before.
- Yeah.
- I'm kinda like, eh.
- I mean two-second faster
loaded of time, right?
- Yeah.
- Oh, the privilege.
(Ashley speaking of mic)
- [Ashley] Oh, we'll increase
our sales for PS4s instead.
- Cool, thanks, Sony.
- Cool, thanks.
- Cheers for that.
- It's 'cause the global
chip shortage, right?
Can't get any devices.
- Yeah.
- Can't get GPs, can't get...
(talking over each other)
- Tablets.
- Can't get service for FF Online.
- You couldn't even get
hash browns at McDonald's
for a while in Japan, did you hear that?
- What, why?
- What?
We had a hash brown shortage
in Japan for a couple of days.
- Oh, is it because the potatoes?
- Yeah, because of the potatoes,
but it was so bad it was to the point
we couldn't even get hash browns.
Wait, wait, why was
there a potato shortage?
- Japan doesn't import potatoes.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah.
- So they only accept like their potatoes
because they believe that theirs...
- So we had a potato shortage.
- We had a potato shortage.
- [Ashley] The french fries,
wasn't it because they couldn't
get salt, like the imports?
- Maybe, I'm pretty sure
Japan doesn't import
the majority of their potatoes.
- Whatever the issue was,
it was all this as a result,
the pandemic, and then
for, I think it was only
for like two or three days.
- Cause they had this a few years ago
with potato chips in Japan, or crisps.
They, yeah, they didn't have any potatoes.
'cause there was, I think
there was a really bad season
and they refused to import potatoes
'cause they saw them as lower quality.
- Yeah.
- You know, that's a load of bull(beep).
A potato's a potato, let's be honest.
- Yeah.
- You're not gonna lie.
So they didn't have any pizza potato chips
and people were really angry.
- Of course, like.
- [Ashley] They do import
the fries are processed
in the US and Canada before
being shipped to Japan.
- Oh, really, they are?
Maybe it's just maybe potato chips then?
- [Ashley] Like shipping disruptions in
on Vancouver's side so we can get...
- Maybe it's just for potato chips then.
Japan is like, or like
maybe Kelpie is like,
no, we only use Japanese.
- We only use Japanese.
- Probably a company thing,
not a like nationwide thing.
Yeah, it makes sense, really.
- And Japan does have this
massive culture around their,
you know, vegetables and
ingredients and where it comes from
and it being high quality, and...
- It needs to come from X Prefecture.
Otherwise it's not right.
- And then you taste it
and you're like this is
just a very good version of
X thing that I normally eat
anyway for 10 times less the price.
- I wanna do a test where
we get the same vegetables.
- That's an after-dark strip.
- Yeah.
- From different prefectures
and see if we can figure it out.
- Or all of the expensive
versus cheap fruits.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We should do that.
- 'Cause I will say like, you know,
there are some fruits where I've had like
you have like Japanese
strawberries, for example,
I don't think I've ever had
a bad Japanese strawberry,
but like it's more of like consistency.
- You had bad strawberries in the UK.
- Yeah, there are some
strawberries where you have
and it's like, it's just not that sweet.
It's like sometimes
a bit sour.
- It's sour.
- It's sour, you know, but
it's still a strawberry.
But every time I buy a packet
of strawberries from Japan,
it's like three, four times the cost,
but every (beep)ing strawberry
is like the sweetest strawberry
you would get from a UK supermarket.
- This is the non-brand.
- It's also sad that they probably waste
a lot more food as well if they throw away
the ones that don't meet the
quality standards, right?
- I don't think it's that.
I think it's just the
quality of like cultivation
is just like incredibly high here
'cause like I remember, I think
I saw this like documentary
about like melons, for example.
- Yeah, I saw that one on YouTube.
- Yeah, the melons one is
like the (beep)ing process
of that is like insane.
Like this guy, this dude in like
in his 50s
- He massages them, right?
Is taking better care of this melon
then some parents do their children.
- Yeah, he was taking
better care of the melons
than I was myself.
- Yeah, right?
So it's just nuts to think that like
okay, yeah, now that I see the process,
I can understand why it's
a little more expensive
and way tastier, but can justify
me paying $300 for a melon.
- I just wish there was a
cheaper option, you know?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I would be fine with it
If there was a natural
option that, you know,
rival the price of the same ingredients
I would pay in like the UK or whatever.
- I think that's the problem.
I remember I used to eat
so much fruit in Australia
just because like an apple
was like less than a dollar.
Yeah, exactly, and it's just
(beep)ing easy to pick up
and it was cheap and it all tasted good.
But like in Japan, like the
cheapest apple you can get
is like 300 Yen or something.
Yeah, pretty tough.
- And it's just like
I can't justify me
spending $3 for an apple.
- Sometimes you want that
high quality experience.
I get that, with every bite that you take,
but sometimes you just wanna
eat a (beep)load of one thing
and not feel guilty afterwards
for spending a lot of money.
- If you eat steak every day,
sometimes you want a hamburger, you know.
- It's just how it is.
- I know Japan doesn't
grow bananas, does it?
I don't think hey can grow here, right?
- What?
- Bananas.
- No
- I don't think..
- I think bananas are all
imported from like Philippines.
- I love the banana gacha, you know,
where you are like.
- Banana gacha?
- You crack open a banana and
you're like, I have no idea
if this banana is gonna
be like (beep) or good
- Right.
- You know what I mean?
- [Ashley] Can grow bananas
in Okinawa, Kogoshima.
- Oh, that makes sense.
- Oh, okay.
- You just never know if
a banana's gonna taste
like the perfect banana, right?
- What is the perfect banana?
- You know when it...
- It depends, right?
Like some people like
are really like brown
and like some people,
- Oh, I hated brown.
- No, I don't like it brown.
You know, you want it to be...
Sometimes you bite into a banana
and it's like fighting back sometimes.
It's like kind of tough.
- I would...
- What the (beep) happened?
- It's got some give.
- Yeah.
- I would prefer a banana be
too ripe than too brown to me.
Like I, prefer.
- No, too ripe,
It's like rock solid.
And it's like...
- I prefer when it's like a, just,
just like a tiny bit of firmness,
just like a tiny bit of
firmness still there.
That's like my perfect banana.
It's not like it's, you know,
it's not completely green,
but it's not like, it's just,
just turns completely yellow.
That's like, to me, that's
like my perfect banana.
- Yeah, I don't like the green ones,
but sometimes even get like
a non-green one and it,
it still is like rock solid or something.
- Yeah, it's like..
I don't even know what I'm
gonna get with these bananas,
and frankly, I quite enjoy that.
I quite enjoy that maybe I'll
get that dog-tear banana.
that its just like really smooth,
kind of little bit sweet, like, ooh,
this is just the perfect banana.
- Why would you ever play a Gashu game
when you just, you can....
- Bananas are the OG Gashu world.
You just never know, never
know if you need a good banana.
That's what I love about bananas.
- It's so sad though
'cause I really miss eating
like a lot of fruits,
but just, I just, again,
I can't justify myself.
- It's like banana is actually
one of the cheaper fruit you eat in Japan.
Plus, it's imported.
(talking over each other)
- Coffee bean, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, like you
know, maybe like three bucks
for like maybe a five or six pack.
- I eat like three bananas a day
because it's just the one
fruit I get at every coffee.
- Real monkey human.
- Huh?
- I actually do, you know
what I realized the other day?
I don't know why, I really,
really like bananas.
- I think it's 'cause
they're like pre-portioned.
- Again.
- They're like the perfect...
- Pre-portioned!
- They're like, we as humans,
we love portioned food.
We love it when something tells us
this is how much you're eating.
- Yeah.
- And the bananas
is the perfect one.
- I really, really love bananas.
I like eat them every day.
- I'm a Jojo fan as well.
- But, but, but.
- I gobble bananas.
- But for some reason I
hate banana-flavored stuff.
Like I dunno why (talking
over each other).
I don't like banana-flavored sweets.
There's just something.
- It depends for me.
- Well, you know, 'cause
the banana-flavored stuff
is from a variety of banana that is,
that we don't use anymore,
it's like extinct.
- Oh really?
- Totally, 'cause it's...
- The artificial banana flavor?
- There is like this after taste
that tastes so artificial that
it just really puts me off.
- So it's like, I think it
was, I don't know if it's the,
if the one we use right now
is the cabin dish banana
or the one before.
I know there's a bunch of
YouTube videos about this.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, there's the one before
apparently is much sweeter,
much better flavor,
but like a plague wiped out that,
like that type of banana.
- Species, yeah.
- So they had to grow another
one that was more resistant.
Problem is that it apparently
doesn't taste as good.
So the original
banana-sweetened flavored stuff
that you taste in stuff,
especially that original banana flavor.
- Yeah.
- Supposedly.
- Right.
- I don't know if it's true.
- I don't mind the artificial.
- I really like the
artificial banana flavor more
than the like real banana flavor.
So I feel like I've been robbed.
- What, you, you like the
artificial banana flavor more?
- Yeah.
- Why?
- Because I feel like I'm missing out
on the OG banana experience.
I feel like I'll come late to the party.
- This mythical banana.
- As a monkey, I feel like
my ancestors had it good.
They had the OG banana, you know,
the sweeter banana, the better banana.
- Have you, have you had a...
- Our ancestors were eating good.
- [Ashley] Extinct banana
flavor is part myth, though.
Banana flavors actually
became more popular
than bananas because nobody had ever
eaten bananas before.
- My God.
The mythical banana.
- 'Cause that's what I taste
when I taste banana-flavored stuff.
It doesn't taste like real banana to me.
- That's because your
concept of real banana
is the only like one that we grow.
That is your real banana flavor is one...
- Is that all a real banana is, Connor?
- That's only one variant of banana.
There's so many bananas
that all taste different.
- You're eating a real banana, or are you?
- Actually like my...
- You are, but there are
more flavors than the flavor you know.
- I know that.
- Resources.
- My favorite banana actually
is Southeast Asian bananas.
I don't like, okay, I
dunno you've ever....
- Like all of Southeast Asia?
- I dunno, but I'm saying Southeast Asian,
because I've only had it in Thailand.
- Huh?
- What about European bananas?
European bananas are the same
(beep)ing bananas that we import, right?
But Southeast Asian bananas are like.
- Really funny out of context though.
- I can't wait for the
banana edit of this.
Jojo fans are talking about dicks.
- Only brought to the
comment section of this clip,
bananarologist, here.
- So, because like in
Thailand you can get like
these really small bananas
that are like half.
- Oh, the finger bananas.
- The finger bananas.
- Yeah. I like those.
- Which is like what they
taste like if you take,
you take one of the four
bananas we are used to
and just pack all that
flavor in half the size.
- It's getting the big banana in...
- Photoshop the banana.
- It's just a shot of banana.
Like I'm like addicted (beep)ing
addicted to those bananas.
'cause like my Dad comes
in with a pack of like,
they don't even sell them
in like, you know, packeted,
they don't sell them in
like packeted bunches.
You just take like, you
just buy them by the bunch.
And like, you buy like a
bunch of like 10 or 20,
and I swear I can get
through like 10 in a day.
Like I like, I like
eat one and I'm like...
(talking over each other)
Yeah, exactly.
Potassium overload.
The (beep)ing ape, the (beep)ing
ape brain just takes over.
I'm just like, (beep)ing
just gimme 10 right now.
- Do, do you think that all
apples have the same taste?
- No, I don't.
- Well then I think that's
the same thing with bananas,
except we just don't have the...
- Don't start this conversation.
- I'm just saying, we don't
have the other bananas, right?
- Where have you had the other bananas?
- I haven't, I want to.
- - No, one's had it.
It's a myth.
- It existed.
- It's literally a myth.
- It's like, you know, all...
- We just established
all of the apple flavors
are really distinctly different, right?
Yeah, yeah.
- It tastes
very, very different.
That's what's we've missed
out on with bananas.
- You're speaking about a mythical banana
that is artificial tasting.
- That may or may not taste like....
- You've never tasted before.
so how can you say that this tastes
like this mythical banana.
You're actually talking
out your (beep) right now.
- I want to try this banana
that I know is gonna taste different.
- What if it doesn't exist?
What if it just.
- It does exist.
- It's completely artificial.
- [Ashley] In his defense, it did exist.
(talking over each other)
- Right, but...
- We can't have it
anymore, Garnt, it's gone.
- It did exist,
but have they perfectly
replicated that flavor
and how do you know?
- How do you know?
- Because we don't have
science back then, you know.
Science was just a guess back then.
- Exactly.
- So how did we know
that this mythical banana tastes the same
as the artificial flavoring?
- You can just, you know,
speculate based on our apples.
- I can speculate what a
(beep)ing dinosaur tastes like,
but I know I'm gonna taste
a (beep)ing dinosaur.
- I bet it tastes like a bear.
- If something came out with
like a (beep)ing
dinosaur-flavored lollipop
or steak or something, I'd be like, cool.
This is completely bull(beep)
because no one's ever
tasted a dinosaur before.
- Isn't it sad we never
got to taste a dinosaur?
I wish we could have tasted a,
like a T-Rex probably tasted great.
We'd be arguing about like a...
- A T-Rex would be gamey as (beep).
Are you (beep)ing kidding me?
- What would be the tastiest dinosaur?
(talking over each other)
RosaRaptor?
- Probably the velociraptor.
- Velociraptor is like...
- Good sized, they're too muscular though.
- Too muscular, that's true,
that would be too tough.
- What's the (beep)ing long necked (beep),
the (beep)ing long...?
- (singing tones) Can
you pass the mustard?
- The brachiosaurus
- Brachiosaurus.
I bet they tasted delicious.
- You know, we missed out on
all these foods and stuff.
You know, that we could have had.
- Trash Taste, we've literally
run out of food we can argue about.
Let's argue about food
that doesn't exist anymore.
- Let's speculate about
(beep) that doesn't exist.
(Ashley speaking off mic)
I can just wake up in a cold sweat
and wonder what bananas
we've missed out on though.
That does happen, that does happen.
- I just don't know if
it's ever crossed your mind
what the word artificial means.
It means it doesn't exist.
- At least I've speculated
of the bananas we've lost.
- What if the bananas we lost
just taste like absolute garbage?
- I would be able sleep at night.
- Probably does because they gone.
- If they taste.
- Extinct
'cause they were little and like bitches
that like Gordon Ramsey didn't like them.
They were extinct because a
plague wiped them out, Garnt.
- What if the plague was...
- based on taste.
- We did you a solid.
We got rid of these (beep)-eatin' bananas.
We'll give you these other ones.
You can imagine what it tastes like.
- (Beep)ing argument that we've had.
- Would you ever want to taste a Dodo
'cause man, if...
- [Ashley] They became
extinct for a reason.
- They weren't extinct
because they got over hunted
so I'm just like, (beep),
how good do these (beep)ing birds taste
- They were over hunted,
for what purpose were they?
They have like a beak that
was special or something?
- Ah, no because...
- I don't know.
Do you know why Ashley?
- [Ashley] I can Google it for you.
- Google it, I'm going to speculate.
Is it because they were
just (beep) weak animals?
- Kind of like, I've heard that dodos
were just like
(beep)ing stupid.
- Just (beep)ing stupid.
- Yeah.
- They're like really
dumb an they were like
if there was a predator
that came up to it,
they wouldn't even know it was a predator.
Like that's how dumb they were supposedly.
- [Ashley] Part of the
reasons is because...
- Look, I've seen Ice Age.
I know exactly what happened.
- Their habitat was almost
completely destroyed
after people started
settling on Mauritius.
- Ah, people.
- You know, this is why, you know,
sometimes I watch those
YouTube videos where it's like,
like the animal, like
there's a tiger eating
a (beep)ing deer or something.
And you go in the comments are like,
"Oh my God, I wish I could
have helped the deer."
It's like, what, stop nature?
Like, what do you mean,
like, what are you gonna do?
Like, I hate these comments
where they're like,
I wish I could've helped that poor Adam.
Like this is literally nature.
Like just let it do its thing.
- We wouldn't be in this
position if it weren't
for where we are right now.
- Yeah we're a plague, all right?
That's fair enough, we
probably not do that (beep).
- [Garnt] We're the
problem, we're the virus.
- When you're asking a lion
not to like eat it's prey,
like no, that's what a lion does.
That's like the whole point.
That's why, that's why everything exists.
Like let it do it, like don't intervene.
- What are you gonna do is
like go to a lion and be like,
just stop.
- Like Yeah.
- And the lion be like,
yeah, you're right, man.
- Have you ever soybeans?
- Veganism, that's an option.
- I think David Attenborough
spoke about this
one time as well, and he
was like, someone asked him
in interview, they're
like, do you ever feel like
sorry for the animals that like,
I think there was one with like the birds
were falling down, and
starve or something.
And he was like, no, you
know, it's just unfortunate.
- That's life.
- That's nature.
It's not our place to intervene,
to get involved and say, who can do what
until obviously we've
burn down all the forests.
- And literally killed the...
- That is kind of on us, we.
- We should probably intervene
as little as possible.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I hate those comments though.
- What is it you wanna say, Ashley?
- [Ashley] There was an animal
that was literally eaten to death though.
I think it was the giant tortoise.
- Most, animals are eaten.
- Yeah, that's on us.
- [Ashley] Ate the whole species to death.
- Okay.
- That's on us, that's on us.
- What animals that?
- [Ashley] I think it
was a giant tortoise.
- How the (beep) to you eat that?
- What, humans?
- How do you even start?
- What's (beep)ing wrong with us?
Well, apparently they make
turtle soup and stuff.
- That's...
- Yeah, but, I dunno.
- I just find it, just
the image of just a guy
looking at a giant tortoise
being like delicious.
- [Ashley] It really was delicious.
- Oh, stop that.
- I don't wanna...
- I don't know, we've
eaten a lot weirder things.
- That is true, that's true.
- If there's something that's breathing,
I'm sure humans have tried
to find a way to eat it.
Maybe humanity just has Trash
Taste, feed source music.
- At the end of the episode.
- Nature is scary, or is it?
- This episode of Trash Taste
with nature and scary things.
- You know what's more
scary though, our patrons?
- That's true, Joey, that's true.
They survive natural selection.
- Yeah, they won't eat the meat.
- What is your favorite banana
that you may own the
may or may never have?
- Tell us your favorite of
banana that you wish you tried.
- Tell us what you think
is the tastiest banana.
- How many variations of
banana are there even?
- Enough to...
- I've only eaten two.
- How do yo you?
- Real and artificial?
- Well, it's the bananas that
are that widely available
a lot around the world and...
- Like 800.
- I'm gonna Google this.
- Oh, there's only 10.
There's only 10 variants.
- [Ashley] There's just 10,
but I think there's more.
- There's loads.
- Is that a top 10?
- [Ashley] It's a top 10, actually.
- Top 10 bananas.
- #10.
(Ashley talking off mic)
- But hey, if you enjoyed the
show and wanna support us,
then make sure to go up to our Patreon,
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter.
Send us your memes on the Subreddit,
and if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
Also tell us what you think
is the tastiest dinosaur.
- And why, and how...
- I want a reason,
how you would cook it.
- Would you dry age?
Would you skillet, I wanna know.
What kind of wood would you use?
- Velociraptal skillet.
- Dry aged T-Rex.
- Oh, yes.
- This episode of Trash Taste.
Bye.
- Bye.
- Oh, my God.
(engaging tones)